on to some other stuff today um apart
from that uh but to begin with I'm going
to read our Chairman's script and then
uh probably give a a few announcements
for our committee for your information
and planning and then we'll get on with
our business with that with the first
hearing so uh mam chair you are you
about ready yes I am thank you okay uh
as chair of the House Education
committee I find that due to the state
of emergency declared by the governor of
the covid-19 pandemic and in accordance
with house rule 67 and the governor's
emergency order number 12 for to
executive order
2020-4 this public body is authorized to
meet
electronically this is a public hearing
appeals referred to the education
committee executive session on pending
legislation may be held please note that
there is no fisal location for members
of the public to observe and listen
contemporaneously to this meeting
however in accordance with the emergency
order I am confirming that all members
of the committee and select legislative
staff have the ability to communicate
contemporaneously during this meeting
through the zoom electronic meeting
platform and the public has access to
contemporaneously listen and if
necessary participate in this meeting by
the zoom platform or by telephone all
necessary access information has been
made available in the house calendar and
through the electronic calendar on the
general court website the notice for
this meeting complies with house rules
and RSA
91a anyone who has a problem at
accessing the meeting should call
271-3600 or email HCS ledge.
state. Us in the event the public is
unable to access the meeting the meeting
will be adjourned and rescheduled I want
to introduce the staff that are on the
meeting assisting us at this time jennif
four is our committee researchers please
note that all votes that are taken
during this meeting shall be done by
roll call vote let's start the meeting
by taking a roll call attendance when
each member states their presence please
also State whether there is anyone in
the room with you during this meeting
which is required under the right to
know law thank you madam cler
yes good morning everyone represent Fort
Aly here in the committee room
representative bone in the committee
room here representative all here with
eight of my
colleagues
represent here in Hudson New Hampshire
still
sick representative m in the house and
healthy have a
gentl
that's oh I didn't recognize you off the
screen
I'm
sorry representative hawson here in the
committee
room representative Andress here home
alone in a room in
Salsbury representative Fort
here here home in Dairy with uh one baby
that's a little upset stomach and uh my
other boy's in the house so I'll see you
guys next week in
person representative sod here in the
committee room representative Miler uh
here in kukuk my wife will be in and out
of the room thank you representative
Luna in
Hopkinson representative Shaw here
representative in the committee room
representative Cornell here home alone
in Manchester representative T here in
Georges Mills part of sunap uh with my
rescue dog
Raven
Ellison uh here home alone and conquered
repr Mullen here in Bedford where nobody
wants to be in the room with
me
represent I am here I am home alone in
Jaffrey W here in sen Conway with my
wife in and out and my dog that may
bark lad
here all present thank you very much
Madam clerk represent luno do you have
your dog with you there you didn't
mention your
dog yeah Aussie's uh Aussie snoozing
downstairs oh good all right um a few
notices for everybody uh we are gonna
have two uh meetings next week on one on
Tuesday one on Thursday those are the
days that have been set aside for this
committee uh I recognize the Tuesday is
also a day in which we have H voting
going on in the
state uh so that we have some bills
which we're hearing there those bills I
mentioned the other day that we have not
yet heard those will be heard uh on
Tuesday Thursday will be a day in which
uh we're going to be definitely
executing uh I did receive word from the
speaker's office uh uh yesterday that
the deadline for getting information out
of committee has been moved forward or
you know forward on the calendar to
April 1 however we're being encouraged
by uh leadership to try and get our work
done as quickly as
possible um so um this does take a
little bit of the Heap off us however we
do have a lot of work to do here so
we're going to try to move forward and
and conduct ourselves and as if we're
trying to get things done that will
leave us a little time in case we have
some issues which require more time I
have also set up a a meeting the first
meeting for for this subgroup I have
that's working on postsecondary
education the merger of the two
Community College of the community
college system and the university system
New Hampshire our first meeting will be
scheduled for Friday of next week at 10
o'clock from 10 o'clock to 12 o'clock I
I have um a represent our not
representative Chancellor McKay Ed McKay
is going to be here helping and present
some information uh others have been
notified I haven't got anything back
from them yet we also have the following
Friday after that uh where we're going
to be meeting uh to also further discuss
this we have some folks out of the
accrediting institution down in in
Boston who have dealt with some of these
merging issues that will be presenting
there and of course others have been
asked as
well so I I look forward to those two
days was a lot of work to be done here
in a very very short period of time the
purpose of that committee is not to come
out with a specific spefic
recommendation as I spoke with represent
luno the other day it's to come out with
a brief which identifies issues both
strengths and weaknesses and we will exp
that shovel it off to division two where
they have to make the decision regarding
um uh
hb2 so with that are there any questions
before we start off into the um the the
hearing for today yes Mr chair you said
the subcommittee meetings were on Friday
the 12 and the 19th that's right both
starting at
10:00 both starting at 10:00 there will
be two hours in length that'll be done
you'll be contacted bya the zoom uh and
that'll become right to your
residents okay we're going to go ahead
with uh today's uh schedule uh the top
uh item for discussion is
cac3 uh that's related to the use of
money raised taxation for
Education um I'd like to recognize
represent cordelli who will be
presenting the the bill
resolution thank you um Mr chairman for
the record I am Glenn cordelli
representing Tuftonboro molten burough
and sandwich in the beautiful Lakes
Region and today I am introducing a
constitutional amendment to repeal the
so-called Blain Amendment or no Aid
Amendment from our
constitution this 187 77 amendment to
our constitution is part two article 3
and States provided nevertheless that no
money raised by taxation shall ever be
granted or applied for the use of the
schools of Institute or of institutions
of any religious sect or
denomination there are two primary
reasons that this repeal should be done
first is the
constitutionality based upon the US
Supreme Court decision in uh espanosa
versus Montana Department of Revenue
case last June these State Blain
amendments are violations of the first
amendment of our US
Constitution I will leave more of on
that uh topic to our next speaker so I
would like to discuss the second reason
for this legislation and this
repeal the Blain amendment is a relic of
a period of anti-religious
bigotry as such it has no place in our
constitution in the mid 1800s the common
School concept was started by Horus man
in Massachusetts with the thought that
in order for a civil society there
needed to be a civil and religious
education for all since our nation was
primarily a Protestant Nation the
schools were no different religion and
reading from Bibles was part of the
common school
education but problems arose with the
migration of Catholics from several
countries but primarily Ireland in order
to escape the Potato Famine these
immigrants arrived here and found that
their children were being taught
religious Concepts contrary to their own
this led to discrimination and
violence in Philadelphia there were
riots over which version of the Bible
was to be used in school
in Maine a Catholic a Catholic Church
was burned and the priest tarred and
feathered and these were not isolated
incidents if you want to look at our
website repeal
nhl.com you will see a famous
1871 uh Cartoon that captured the M mood
of the nation it shows crocodiles
representing Catholic priests
approaching the shoreline where a
teacher is protecting students from
these Catholic
priests as these non-protestant groups
began to form their own schools there
was a backlash The Establishment
Protestant groups did not want these sex
like Catholics which gave term to the
term sectarian to have access to public
funds for
Education school funding rather than
School prayer and bibles became an issue
and a political issue in
1875 president ulyses S Grant gave a
speech calling for a constitutional
amendment to forbid States from using
public funds for any school that taught
sectarian AKA Catholic
tenants James Blaine of Maine was the
speaker of the United States House of
Representatives and a friend of
President
Grant soon
after a grant speech Blaine introduced a
constittution tional Amendment providing
that no state raised tax funds be
provided to any religious sect Blain
envisioned himself to be uh the next
president of the United States and this
would be an issue that would bring him
that
presidency the amendment passed the US
house but fell just short of the
necessary two-thirds votes in the Senate
but the anti-catholic movement did not
end there states began adopting their
own blame type amendments and today
there are some 38 states with such
amendments the New Hampshire
Constitution was amended just two years
later in
1877 to include the Blain Amendment it
was clearly modeled after the failed US
Constitution amendment to extend
anti-religious anti-catholic
prohibitions but attempts to defend
common schools continued in numerous
locations into the 20th
centuries I will note that many of these
efforts were promoted by the clue plux
Clan uh including very much so in Maine
bla amends were Blain amendments were
born of bigotry religious bigotry is no
better than racial
bigotry we have seen um the Uproar about
Dr Zeus Seuss recently um tearing down
of statues around the country including
George Washington Abraham Lincoln uh
we've seen a statue defaced with red
paint here in New Hampshire and other
calls for other statutes to be
removed but what needs to be torn down
are the statutes that promote
bigotry New Hampshire needs to repeal
this now un unconstitutional remnant of
anti-religious anti-catholic
bigotry I have introduced this amendment
to do just that this should not be a
political issue the Blain Amendment
repeal should bring us together so that
we can eliminate this remnant of
bigotry Mr chairman I would appreciate
uh to defer questions um I believe our
next speaker has another appointment and
I I asked that uh she could be uh
promoted next and I would be glad to
take questions after her testimony thank
you very much uh we we'll go ahead with
that um can you please uh get the the
person wants to add on to Erica Smith
yes okay Erica I promoted you uh go
ahead
please thank you Mr chair Representative
cordelli members of the committee thank
you for inviting me to testify my name
is Erica Smith I'm a constitutional
lawyer and a senior Attorney At The
Institute for justice I was also one of
the lead attorneys on the esposa case
that many of you are familiar with and
that representative cordelli mentioned
uh I urge you you to repeal the Blain
Amendment for three reasons first as
representative cordelli testified this
amendment has a ugly history that is
very well documented and it would be
really important to remove this Mark of
bigotry from the New Hampshire
Constitution Second is for
constitutional
reasons that it is very hard to think of
a situation where the Blain Amendment
could be constitutionally applied and
that's because of two recent Supreme
Court decisions uh the first was the
Trinity Lutheran case that came out in
2018 in that case the court found that
Missouri's Blain Amendment could not be
constitutionally applied to exclude a
religious preschool from participating
in a state grant
program and then just last summer the
Supreme Court said that Montana's Blain
Amendment could not be constitutionally
applied
to exclude religious schools from
participating in a school choice
program after these decisions it's very
very difficult to think how could the
Blain Amendment be constitutionally
applied and that's because we already
have the federal establishment clause
which already protects separation of
church and state so when you look at
what the bla amendment is doing beyond
the federal Establishment Clause all
it's doing is discriminating against
religion and that violat the federal
protections for free
exercise the third reason for supporting
its repeal is by keeping it in a New
Hampshire Constitution you are inviting
frivolous
litigation especially when it comes to
school choice programs you Hampshire has
a school choice program they're
currently considering expanding one of
their programs and passing another one
as long as this is in the Constitution
school choice opponents are going to
seize on it to bring lawsuits against
these programs these lawsuits will be
completely frivolous and the state will
win in defending the programs but it's
still going to cost the state a lot of
time and a lot of money to defend these
frivolous lawsuits and we shouldn't have
to worry about that I'm just going to
make one final point and that's about
the aclu's written testimony uh I have a
lot of respect for the ACLU we work with
them on a lot of issues but we are on
opposite sides when it comes to this and
I'd like to note that their test money
talks about the validity of the Blain
Amendment but it doesn't even address
the Trinity Lutheran or espanosa
decision I think I think it's um very
difficult to have a meaningful
conversation about the bla Amendment
without talking about the Supreme Court
opinions uh the written testimony from
the ACLU also argues that the Blain
amendment is actually doing a good thing
by excluding religious schools from
school choice programs I'm not sure how
they can say that considering that we
now know that excluding religious
schools from a school choice program is
unconstitutional as the Supreme Court
just said last summer so with that I
will uh take any questions thank you
very much very much Miss Smith uh
represent
Miler uh thank you uh councelor Smith
for being with us today since you've
been involved in both the uh well you've
involved in the espanosa case but are
well aware of the Trinity case could
youe for the committee specifically
outline the issues in each of those
cases so that we're clear on what was
the basis for those cases thank you very
much sure of course uh so the what those
cases both came down to is that the
government has to be neutral toward
religion and religious institutions they
can't preference them um they also can't
discriminate against them they have to
be neutral and in both cases the Supreme
Court found that the Blain amendment was
not being neutral and was instead
discriminating against religious
institutions and religious schools and I
could talk about the facts in each of
those case cases so in Trinity Lutheran
what had happened was that a uh Missouri
had a state grant program to allow
schools um and other education entities
to refurbish their playgrounds uh there
was a whole bunch of groups that applied
for this Grant including a religious
preschool and daycare uh and the state
said I'm sorry uh you qualify the F this
grant but we're going to have to exclude
you because of our Blain Amendment
because you are religious and we can't
give funds to a religious entity this
went all the way up to the Supreme Court
and the Supreme Court said absolutely
not this is discriminating against
religion that violates the free exercise
clause you have to treat them equally to
non-religious groups
what H something similar happened in
Espinosa Montana had passed a school
choice program uh that was meant to
allow children to choose to attend the
school of their choice whether that was
a religious school or a non-religious
school but the agency the state agency
that was supposed to administer the
program that was the Department of
Revenue passed a rule that said children
could only use the scholarships to
attend nonreligious schools and they
based that on Montana's Blain Amendment
this went all the way up to the US
Supreme Court again and the court again
said you cannot apply the Blain
amendment to exclude religious schools
from this other from the a school choice
program this is a generally available
program uh everyone is supposed to
participate and if you discriminate
against some people just because of
their religious status their religious
character you are violating the free
exercise clause thank you for the
clarification thank you very much are
there further questions
for thank you Mr chair and thank you
Miss Smith for taking the question
listening to your testimony I going
correct that if the C cacr even failed
there would be pretty much no impact on
Choice program because of those two
decisions that you
mentioned um representative Elson as I
said um by keeping this in the
Constitution you are inviting lawsuits
those lawsuits will ultimately fail
because of the Supreme Court decisions
but in the meantime the state is going
to have to spend a lot of time and money
defending them uh sometimes these
lawsuits can cost over
$100,000 uh it's just because someone
brings a frivolous lawsuit you still
have to defend against it so that's just
one more reason to remove this provision
from the Constitution thank you thank
you representative s I think she covered
it oh you got okay thank you are there
further questions from the committee oh
yes represent tan uh thank you for
taking my question um you've been
everybody's been talking about the
Blaine amendment to this point but um in
the New Hampshire
Constitution um article six of um
Amendment the First Amendment uh under
morality and piety has a specific
statement and this was written in 17 84
that no person shall be compelled to pay
towards the support of the of the
schools of any sect or denomination
which seems to predate the Blain
amendment that everybody seems to be
hammering on um I'm just wondering if if
that isn't a clear indication of what
the founders at least of our
constitution in New Hampshire really
wanted to have
happen uh thank you representative
Tanner for that question my
understanding is that the new New
Hampshire Supreme Court has interpreted
that provision to just provide the same
protections that the federal
Establishment Clause provides um so
again neutrality toward religion not
discrimination toward religion may I
have a followup on
that um could you give me the um case
for that please uh I don't have uh I
don't have it off the top of my head
representative Tanner but I'm happy to
follow with you after the committee
meeting with that
information further questions from the
committee yes representative M thank you
Mr chair this is a history question is
supposal legal question which you may
not be able to speak to but but uh Blain
was a main Republican he ran for
president uh St Republican and the the
Catholic Church throughout most of our
history certainly in the 19th century
was overwhelmingly Democrat so I'm
wondering I don't know if you can speak
to this but I'm very interested in this
in that was were these Blain amendments
more than just uh religious based or was
there a political component to also uh
diminish uh the Democrats or democrat
Catholics or is that anything that you
have uh have heard
about I'm not sure if I could comment on
that specific spefically I can tell you
that representative Blaine um well he
was also a senator he was a
representative um he had very he had a
lot of political aspirations and wanted
to run for president of the United
States and this anti-catholicism was not
just happening in his state but across
the country and he was very opportun
opportunistic and he wanted to run on
this anti- Catholic sentiment that was
going across the entire country and he
was hoping it would launch him into the
White House
yes thank you the the the it's been
posited that this is not only religious
bigotry but a political way for Blaine
and and the Republicans of the time to
diminish Democrats which which I think
is uh is potentially interesting thank
you thank you thank you very much are
are there further questions for the
person for Miss
Smith not seeing any hands thank you
very much Erica
thank you are there any questions for
represent cordelli before we um go
on not see any um well thank you very
much represent cordelli do we have the
next uh indivual the next speaker is
representative Mark Pearson and I
promoted
him welcome representative
Pearson I think you're
you're muted
representative yeah thank you Mr
chairman and members of the committee
for the record I am Mark Pearson
representing Atkinson Hamstead Kingston
and plastow and I'm chairman of the
health human services and elderly
Affairs Committee of the New Hampshire
House of
Representatives I grew up in a
multiethnic miltown in Eastern
Massachusetts It embarrasses me to tell
you that my grandmother was a
bigot even at an early age I couldn't
understand her hate one day when I was
about eight I asked her Nana do you hate
the Irish the French Canadians and the
Italians because they're Catholic or do
you hate Catholics because they're Irish
French Canadians and Italians her answer
was
yes where did that bigotry come from one
answer is what theologians call Original
Sin which some people word as that
latent hidden propensity to Badness
everyone has to some degree or other
whether we acknowledge it or not but
secondly and not to excuse her Nana was
a product of her time I'm going to skip
a fair bit of my testimony at this point
because the previous two speakers have
well rehearsed the Blain Amendment and
that white anglosaxon protest an no
nothing movement they were called No
nothings because when they were
challenged about the group that was
trying to put Catholics and ethnics in
their place they claimed to know nothing
I might say ironically they may have
been right they believed there was this
popish conspiracy to subvert white
anglosaxon Protestant America by other
religions and
immigrants
while
barely failing to succeed nationally the
Blain Amendment language did get into a
number of state constitutions now
whatever one thinks about how funding
for public schools is raised whatever
one thinks about charter schools and
whatever one thinks about Aid to schools
that are not public I believe those
decisions should be based on 21st
century thinking and on 19th century
bigotry as we now are looking back over
our shoulders to those we once hailed as
Great American heroes and admit their
various faults and failures and
sometimes act in response I think we
need to do the same both to
ourselves and to our own foundational
documents to see if similar changes are
in order while I'm ashamed of Nana's
bigotry I'm grateful for my grand
Father's Love of all people across the
ethnic and racial spectrum and I wish
his
inclusivity and not Nana's bigotry would
Prevail in the language of our New
Hampshire
Constitution thank you Mr chairman and
members of the committee thank you very
much representative are you willing to
take questions no I believe you have
numbers of speakers and the questions
would probably be better answered by
Representatives Spain and others thank
you very much thank you sir
welcome okay next speaker um is
representative Tim Horgan uh go ahead
please oh thank you very much Mr chair
um so my name is represented Timothy
Horan I represent the towns of Durham
and Madbury um first of all just in the
interest of full disclosure um we were
talking about U President Grant um few
minutes ago he happens uh he happens to
be a uh first cousin uh I think two or
three times removed on my mother's side
and actually this uh flag that I have
here hanging in the background if you
see it I CH specifically because it was
the union um flag the union flew under
led by President Grant in the Civil War
so I I uh obviously he was a little bit
before my time so I haven't discussed
his views on Race but I I don't feel he
was a uh I don't feel he was a bigot the
um oh the other thing was uh the rent
cardelli brought up Dr Zeus I'm a
liberal Democrat I'm also like great
admirer of do Zeus and I'm very sad
those books were are been taken off the
market but that was a business decision
by U basically by the Zeus estate I
don't support that I i' never called for
any of those books to be uh to be pulled
for the shelves especially not on Beyond
zebra which is one of my favorites
anyway to get I just um I say this is is
a uh this uh this amendment um is uh
first of all it's unnecessary because we
have a very rich uh network of religious
schools which um may not get uh direct
uh direct State funding and I think it's
good that they don't get direct State
funding but also they do they are
heavily subsidized um there was I
noticed in an oped piece R cordelli
yes am I going off topic too much anyway
so this this amendment um
I think we should not be directly
supporting schools of any sect um and uh
I think this is a uh I think the
uh article 83 should stay the way it is
um if we do anything to it and this
would be within the priew of the
Commerce Committee we should probably uh
strengthen the second half of it which
has to do with corporations because that
was trying to prevent a lot of abuses by
corporations which are I think that
article part of the article is
uh is not really being not really being
observed but anyway
so we should uh we should not be a
directly subsized religious
organizations and also this is also a
question of freedom of church from State
um so this is a we anybody we give money
to we and I don't have a terrible thing
problem with that but we have to
regulate them so we would be uh that
would be the church would then be uh
regulating the operations of these
religious institutions and um so
finally also I've been opposed to the
school choice um Choice bills and that's
not because I'm a bigot um I don't think
my objections to that are frivolous so
that's um so I'd like to be the first to
say no to the Constitutional amendment I
might might also add
UE probably should have probably
considering any constitutional amendment
in the first year the buying is a waste
of time because the people had voted on
until November 20 202 so this is not a
good
time be considering it and even 2022 is
probably not a good time to be voting
out going to be a lot more pressing
issues for the voters to consider so
that's a so that's I'm opposed to the
bill and I urge you to to itl it and I
guess I'd be happy to take any questions
if anybody should feel like asking me
any thank you very much representative
are there any questions for represent
Oran representative M thank you m thank
you representative foran for taking my
question my question simply is
do you find any irony in the fact that
the bla amendment was put into place
around the country by Republicans to to
damage a a strong Democratic
constituency uh and and yet you're seem
to be defending uh the imposition of
these amendments by uh bigoted
Republicans uh well that was uh that was
a few years ago that was before that was
before my time I I just ECT that uh
General Grant would not be supporter of
today's Republican party if he were
still alive today obviously he'd be what
180 years old so so today's Republican
party is not the Republican party of
Lincoln and Grant today's Democratic
party is not the uh it's not the uh it's
not the party of the Democrats at that
time and uh
also and part of it also I think has to
do with the union movement which the
Democrats were a supporter of back then
which actually the Catholic church had a
large role in supporting and so today
the Democratic party is the party that
supports workers rights organized and
that was case to some extent back then
but so they the this basically dividing
line between new parties is totally
different than it was now so you know
that was uh I really can't imagine that
ulyses S Grant could have been a member
of today's Republican party I I just uh
thank you what he beli the opposite of
what today's Republicans believe in my
opinion thank you very much uh further
questions not see any hands thank you
very much thank you next we have
representative Walt stapon and he's been
promoted welcome to education welcome
representative thank you Mr chair and
members of the committee committee for
the record um Walter Stapleton a
representative from from Claremont
representing ward 3 Sullivan County
District
5 um I had uh prepared some remarks but
they were already more than adequately
covered by the presenter and first
speakers so I'm just going to cut it
short u um and and and say that uh I'm a
I'm am in support of cacr
three because while our culture has
generally matured out of the ious
against Catholic and religious
schools many of the Blain amendments
still reside in several state
constitutions like ours here in New
Hampshire at article
83 but not in article six Bill of Rights
referenced uh by representative Tanner
and I thank her for uh bringing our
attention to that particular article um
and it was correct um but no person
shall ever be compelled to pay towards
the suppor of schools or any sect or
denomination but it goes
on uh and every person denomination or
sect shall be equally under the
protection of the law and no
subordination of any one sect
denomination or persuasion to another
shall ever be established this is truly
the image of the sword of Justice uh
that cuts both ways um the double-edged
sword if you will um and so it's not a
Prohibition article 6 against Aid to um
religious denominational schools but
establishes that um our our state is
definitely against bigotry and uh
suppression of religious ideals and U
and beliefs so it has to be read in read
in its fully full context and of course
it is under the first part the Bill of
Rights uh so this is not a Prohibition
but this is a declaration of uh the
rights of all persons and all faiths and
denominations most religious schools in
America have been recognized as having
quality academic programs and notable
student outcomes which equal or exceed
those of many any public schools
religious schools are as much a valued
asset for our adequate education goals
as other component assets of public
private and Charter
Schools especially when they can benefit
a spectrum of students with special
needs that may not be available at their
resident Public
Schools so it's time to remove those
outdated impediments to full educational
asset
utilization by removing this
discriminatory language from our state
constitution please find cacr 3 as ought
to pass and thank you for the
opportunity to testify thank you very
much representative are there questions
for the
representative I'm not seeing any I'm
not seeing any it thank very much thank
you and um next we have former Chief
Justice Representative Bob Lynn welcome
to education welcome Justice
Lynn you're you're
onself thank you very much and thank you
for permitting me to testify uh I uh
most of of what I would have to say
really has been has been has already
been said and I know the committee has
got a lot of work today so I won't spend
a lot of time but I would just say I am
a strong supporter of this uh of this
amendment and you know i h i I have to
say and I think maybe just just for some
some
perspective um I that I bring to this um
I was raised as a Catholic I still
consider myself a Catholic although I'll
to to be very honest with you I'm not
sure I would classify myself as a very
good Catholic I don't go to church
regularly I'm not a particularly
religious person uh my wife is Jewish um
we raised our our son uh in the Jewish
faith um and he's uh and my wife I I
think would probably say that she's not
a particularly religious person either
and neither is my son um I and I say all
that because um I think it's important
to understand that to the extent there's
a suggestion that it is sort of
religious
zealots that are the people that are
supporting this amendment I don't think
that's true it's certainly not true in
my case I am not in any sense um uh
religious zealot but I do think uh for
the reasons that um
the uh the prior speakers have have said
that this this amendment is really um uh
uh I'm sorry this the the the provision
of the Blain Amendment that's currently
in the constitution is really a relic of
of anti-catholic discrimination uh that
that we should not permit to remain in
the Constitution and I think it's true
that um uh as as uh one of the speakers
said who was involved involved in the
challenges in the espanosa case and and
The Trinity Lutheran case that if this
does even though this this amend this
language in the current constitution is
not uh will not be effective anymore
because of the federal Supreme Court
decisions um the fact that it's in there
um will give you know excuses for
litigation um uh based on the state
constitution in the hopes that somehow
uh you know you can you could get uh the
the state supreme court to to construe
the the the provision to to uphold its
validity and in some way you know
uh carve out some exception from what
this from what the uh US Supreme Court
has said it'll cost everybody a lot of
money it's not worth it and it's it's
also not worth having in the
Constitution a provision that U that is
inv valid and that has such um a really
sort of pernicious history of where it
came from and what it was based upon um
so for all those reasons um I urge the
committee to to uh uh vote this uh
proposed amendment as ought to pass and
I'm happy to take any questions um that
anybody might have thanks very much uh
justice Lynn are there questions
for Bob Lynn I I have a question for you
uh Mr Lynn um we heard earlier this
morning from uh attorney uh Smith um
that it would be frivolous for a lawsuit
to be brought uh in the State uh and be
live the gate against the Blain
Amendment do you also agree it would be
frivilous uh to uh bring a lawsuit
fourth in this
state you know it would it would be hard
I think it's I I think it's hard to to
say that as a blanket matter without
knowing exactly what the what the
legislation would uh what what the
lawsuit was about for example I I as I
understand the the current case law from
the US Supreme Court for example I think
that that if New Hampshire were to pass
a law that
allowed for for some kind of Public
Funding of
actual relig of Public Funding of of a
school that
taught that taught people how to become
clergymen I think that there is a supre
a US Supreme Court case from the state
of Washington I don't remember the name
right now but it's relatively recent
case that said that it was all right for
uh a state to prevent that in other
words if the if the if it's not simply
preventing funding to religious schools
um that might happen to teach religion
as a course along with history and math
and all that um that's perfectly okay
and the state can't discriminate against
that but if a but what a State might be
able to do is say we are not going to
provide uh Public Funding for a school
that teaches you to become a priest or a
rabbi or a a uh you know Protestant
clergyman if that's the purpose of it
that might that might go too far so I
suppose and I mean I'm not aware if
there's any such proposal in the New
Hampshire legislature but if there was
one like that um I suppose that you know
that might be a place where um the Blain
Amendment would have some validity
although I although it's I I I would
think that that that anything that would
violate the Blain that would be
permissible under the Blain Amendment
would very likely be permissible under
the Federal Constitution anyway so again
it's really it it's it's really sort of
theoretical more than more than anything
else I appreciate your taking a time to
explain that to me thank you um are
there further further questions up from
committee
members thank you very much B thank you
very thank you welcome next we have H
representative Norm Silber welcome to
education thank you very much thank you
Mr chair and the members of the
committee uh I would like to speak ly in
support of cacr 3 and uh that it's she
ought to
pass I've written in the past about the
bla Amendment the history of the bla
Amendment it's a really sorry history in
our country's background the Blain
amendment in our constitution I believe
perpetuates and embodies bigotry and
anti Catholic
discrimination as has been discussed by
The Institute of Justice representative
in the two cases that have been before
The Supreme Court recently the the
Supreme Court is held that these types
of Provisions in as applied violate the
first amendment protection of freedom of
religion and freedom of exercise I
believe that there's an ultimate irony
that we in New Hampshire have this in
our constitution considering how many
French Canadian Catholics move down
across the border and settled
particularly in the North Country so we
have a very large Catholic population in
the state and it's really ironic that we
have a Blain Amendment still in our
constitution it is a stain on our state
it's a stain on the reputation of our
state and it's just plain wrong and
really needs to be taken out of our
constitution so I urge you to pass cacr
3 as an OTP thank you thank you very
much Mr Silver are there questions for
Norm
Silber looking around I do not see any
hands up thank you very much thank you
very much thank you next we have
representative Al Al baldasaro welcome
to
education oh thank you um Mr chairman uh
committee members uh this is
representative Al Bal deyro calling in
from an undisclosed
location uh but um I am in support of C
uh 3 and let me explain the reasons why
uh you know of I'm a father of seven
children and four stepchildren uh my
four stepchildren were in Christian
School my seven children uh at the time
as a marine couldn't afford it uh which
I would have preferred because I'm one
who moved my kids out of one state into
another state because of the education
was terrible where they were at but this
basically is a housekeeping pretty much
a housekeeping Bill and what it is is
correcting a um something that should be
removed from the Constitution that our
Supreme Court uh New Hampshire Supreme
Court and the US Supreme Court had made
decision uh you've had some great
speakers that came forward and broke it
down in the law so I'm going to leave it
at that that this is a no-brainer for
republicans and Democrats uh to correct
this and maybe save the state some money
down the road for any type of litigation
and I thank you for taking my testimony
uh but one thing I did try to sign up on
the site and I could not sign in as to
speak but I did you know sign up and
supported the Bill thank you thank you
very much represent I hope it's a little
bit sunnier down there on your neck of
the woods oh it is it's about uh 80
degrees
out oh thanks thank you that's
encouraging are there any questions for
represent
B I don't see any thank you very much Al
thank you sir bye
okay next we have uh David DH um go
ahead David I've promoted you welcome to
education welcome back education
represent thank you thank you Mr
chairman and uh thank you to the
committee for hearing my
testimony uh I will be brief um I did
send a letter to the committee uh so I
think it's pretty apparent what My Views
are on this bill I I uh
I'm encouraging the house education
committee to itl cacr
3 um I have a kind of I think the people
with whom I served on education know
that I oppose State funding for private
schools I've consistently spoken against
that and I will continue to speak
against it um I'm not sure I'm not sure
what the reasons for for the Blain
Amendment at the time but um my personal
background is that I spent almost half
my career in uh private parochial
schools uh I'm I have nothing against
them whatsoever I respect people who
work in them I think there is dedicated
as public schools teachers I sent my um
children to private
schools um was very pleased with the
education they
received um but I don't think the state
should fund private education and I
think opening this door uh by this
amendment would uh just be another crack
in the foundation of public
education um and I really would
encourage the committee to work toward
um sufficiently funding public education
rather than
working uh to its detriment so uh I hope
my letter explains my opposition I won't
take up more of your time I appreciate
your time Mr chair members of the
committee uh thank you for your
consideration thank you very much uh
honorable dhy uh are there any questions
for for
Dave I I I have one for you Dave um in
in our state right now we currently uh
support uh through our costume formula
students that are attending Public
Schools students that are attending uh
schools in two other states new
uh which have been approved by the
Department of Education both in austa
andar we uh allow uh students in our
tuition program to attend uh schools
which have been approved by the local
school boards both uh private and public
and so I'm I'm I'm really wondering uh
where we're presently supporting uh
students in the state to attend private
schools
that are approved by the department why
is it that we can't send our kids to a
private school that is accredited that
is approved but is a religious school is
it the costing or is it the the issue
we've been addressing this bill the
Discrimination well I think that's I
think discrimination is a big part of it
I think accountability is a big part of
it um I I understand that private
schools have
criteria of their own that they uh that
they meet and I I think in in some
circumstances geographical circumstances
if there's absolutely no other option uh
it might be something to consider but I
don't think I don't think we should open
the door for State funding of private
education
universally thank you very much Dave
represent Miler thank you Mr chairman
and thank you for being here uh David
dhy
uh in your in your experience as a
school counselor as you dealt with kids
Etc uh isn't it I mean we've talked this
morning about the Blain amendment being
discriminatory but isn't it
true that some religious schools also
discriminate against who can get into
their school based upon their personal
tenants and beliefs so it's it's a bit
of an irony that we're talking about
blame being discrimina against Catholics
or whomever it might be but then schools
can also religious schools private
schools can then discriminate against
who comes in isn't that correct it is
correct and and I have no problem with
private schools being discriminatory
that's their right correct to do that I
just don't think the state should fund
that
discrimination thank you you're welcome
question
thank you for taking my question Mr
Jordy and thank you for allowing me um
RSA for Child Benefits Services allows
for towns to provide funds to religious
schools based on Town vote do you
believe this should be
replaced uh I'm I'm sorry I didn't quite
get the whole question Representatives
um
rsas uh for child Benefit Services allow
for towns to provide funds to religious
schools Based On A Boat do you believe
this should be
replaced not if not if the there's local
control and lo the local Town votes some
kind of funding that may be uh
particularly
um for that a student in a particular
situation um so no I don't have any
objection to that although I must say
I'm not familiar with that RSA off the
top of my head
okay thank you very much thank you thank
you very much uh represent D I do have
one followup question here um within our
state um and it's been mentioned in this
discussion uh between you and others on
the committee and myself that um private
schools have the ability to reject uh
application of a student or to accept a
student in that school but are you aware
that we have public schools that are
under contract with public school
districts sending districts that also
Reserve that same right to reject
students uh if there are public schools
that reject students from their own
District I'm not familiar with them I've
never had seen that situation in any
public school that I've been in yeah I
better follow up just clarify what I'm
saying we do have some districts that
are receiving districts from a smaller
District like k28 or a K24 that reserve
the right by contract to Res uh to uh
screen students and accept uh various
types of students so they they have a
right to say
no I guess if the school board of that
District makes that decision that's
their right they have the right to
control their own policies in their own
school but uh I guess I'd have to look
at the uh specifics to see if it was
actually
discriminatory thank you very much uh
further
questions represent
dhy um Mr
chair yeah I actually it's a it's a
question to you um uh following up on a
question you had to um representative
dhy with respect to um school districts
or
towns um Contracting with um with uh
private schools for for placing students
so I'm I'm aware of RSA
193 colon 3 Roman 6 which um which which
allows for that uh if there is no public
school for the child child's grade in
the Resident District are there other
statutes is there another statute you
were referencing within the tuition
program statute I don't have that
statute number in front of me right now
but uh they are allowed to tuition
their students to non-sectarian private
schools and they are the ones who
approve that school not the State Board
the local school board does the approval
process right and and and and followup
Mr chair that's that's even if the um
even if that town or School District
provides a public school um that has a
you know that that offers um um
education for the grade for that child
yeah I'm talking about a district right
now that might be a k through six K
through 8 K through 4 they can send the
students to the receiving school that
doesn't you know has the grades that
they don't in the rest of I think we're
talking about the same we're talking
about the same statute then um U Mr
chair so it is it's 193 col 3 Roman six
but it does require the district not to
have a it says if there is no Public
School for the child's grade in the
Resident District uh the school board
May assign the child to another Public
School in another school district or to
any nonsectarian private school that has
been approved as a school tuition
program by the school board so yeah they
so we're referring to the same um to the
same statute I believe Mr chair I'm also
referring to the compulsory attendance
statute where if a student is attending
a school in another state Maine and um
Vermont which is has the interstate uh
contact with our state and if those
States approve that school then it's
it's reciprocal we will we will also
accept that approval status right but M
Mr chair the compulsory attendance is a
completely different um um requirement
and and what what that's saying is that
if you're between the ages of six seven
and 18 something like that um you better
be attending either your public school a
public school in another District a
private school in New Hampshire a
private school approved by another state
a charter school or be homeschooled um
it's just saying you've got to be in
school um um what what you're what what
you were I think um directing to um to
representative DH was was the ability
for a school district to contract with
with a private school but they can only
do so in specific instances when the
grade is grade level programming is not
offered in that school
district yeah and that's that's correct
so what I what is the point to this
conversation is that we do have uh
Public Schools making contracts with
receiving schools that are identified by
that statute we're talking
about I I think we can have this
conversation till the moon comes up
again but uh let's go ahead and have a
few more uh folks testifying today thank
you Mr DH thank you very
much um next um next up is Jody
Underwood um I promoted you go ahead
please you have to unmute
yeah sorry about that just assume that
would happen automatically when you got
me started okay um for the record my
name is Jody Underwood I am Vice chair
of the Cen school board and we are a
tuition in school district
to reiterate what others have said
briefly the US Supreme Court recently
ruled in Espinosa versus Montana that if
a school choice program includes private
schools it can't exclude religious
private schools New Hampshire's Town
tuition program is such a school a
choice program so that ruling applies to
us as a short aside a couple of
Representatives objected to religious
schools getting State funding if cacr 3
passes but that's not the case this is
all local funding so
just for the record um so on the one
hand it might seem safe to just leave
the Now non-functional text in place and
simply ignore it as some people have
suggested but on the other hand the
heart and soul of legal argument as it's
practiced in this country is to look for
ways to distinguish a new case from
previous precedents so long as the text
remains it'll be a temptation to both
plaintiffs and judges to look for some
way to say yes we know what the Supreme
Court said about Montana's program but
this is
different so on a deeper level we
already encourage judges to ignore the
plain language of constitutions for
example when they rule that quote no law
abridging the freedom of speech unquote
doesn't include laws restricting what
you can say during an election or when
they rule that the quote right of the
people to keep and bear arms shall not
be infringed unquote doesn't mean that
arms can't be taxed restricted and
sometimes banned or that some people
can't be prohibited from bearing some
arms in some
places so the Blain amendment is dead at
a federal level um so let's not leaving
sorry let's not leave it lying around
for judges to make it
Undead um that is my testimony I would
be happy to take questions about this or
about town tuition thank very much Miss
Underwood are there questions from the
committee thank you very much all right
thank you welcome next up we have Mar
bfield I've promoted you go ahead please
welcome to
education thank you for taking my
testimony um I will send in written
testimony after I speak and as I'm
looking through it I'm not going to
repeat a lot of what I put in here
because other people have mentioned it
so I in the interest of time I'm going
to skip quite a bit of it but I do want
to bring up a couple things um you know
some of you may look at the removal of
the Blain Amendment as something
centered on school choice but the real
issue is whether you stand for religious
bigotry or
not one can support the removal of the
Blain Amendment because of its
historical roots that was based on
religious big
bigotry and debate the merits of school
choice I have opposed some school choice
options at the federal level I agreed
with the Heritage Foundation when they
opposed Betsy Devo's Federal voucher
program but I support support the
removal of the Blain Amendment from the
New Hampshire Constitution so I do think
that that um you know you can look at it
in that way you you can look at each
school choice proposal and give it its
own Merit and discuss and debate whether
it's good for New Hampshire but this
amendment should be removed from the
state constitution based on everything
we've heard here
today yes superintendents do tuition out
their students and sometimes that's to
religious
schools
um the other point that seems that has
been brought up is this idea of
discrimination um in private schools but
you heard from a parent just a few days
ago during the bullying legislation to
remove um so parents can can uh file a
lawsuit in that with if that law were to
to pass you heard from Shannon bushard
who talked about how her daughter was
bullied in her public school and that
she looked to two different other public
schools to take her kids and they to
take her daughter and they
refused so I think it's important you
know I mean as as we're going back and
forth with these
debates uh it it it seems to be taking
away from the real issue which is this
amendment and let's focus on what this
amendment how it came about what it
stands for and how it is a stain on our
New Hampshire Constitution right now by
all means you you can oppose school
choice programs that come before you as
I said I have opposed the federal school
choice program voucher program but this
amendment stands on its own let's look
at this amendment and whether you agree
or oppose school choice this amendment
needs to be removed um I'm not going to
take up any more of your time I just
wanted to bring those few points up I
thank you for for taking my testimony
thank you very much Miss Banfield are
there questions for an
Marie not seeing any hands up there
thank you very much
an okay next we have Ken Barnes go ahead
Mr Barnes I've promoted you welcome to
education uh I'm sorry uh this is Ken
Barnes and I am pleased to be here I
appreciate uh Mr chair and members of
the committee you're giving me the
opportunity to speak and uh I speak in
opposition to cicr 3 I ask you to itl it
uh for a number of reasons and a lot of
them have already been discussed I won't
uh burden you with uh repeating him but
let me first pick up on what's been an
underlying theme throughout
this hearing and in particular in the
words of the uh immediate uh past
speaker uh she said that the question is
whether you oppose religious bigotry or
not and uh other people have made
reference to the way the Blain amendment
was
initially uh enacted as a bigoted uh by
bigoted people perhaps uh 150 years ago
but this uh prohibition on state funding
to religious schools is plainly not what
you would call religious bigotry it
doesn't say anybody can't practice their
religion can't doesn't say anybody can't
go to parochial schools if they want to
it only applies the state
funding uh of religious schools and that
is in
conformance with the uh us and New
Hampshire
constitutions uh Set uh very important
principle of separation of church and
state and uh I don't think that I have
heard anybody any previous speaker
mentioned the word separation of church
and state but I suggest that that is a
fundamental principle in the United
States and in New Hampshire and uh the
that is really the purpose that is
served from separating State funding
from religious school SCH nobody's
prohibited from sending their kids to
religious
schools uh just that the state is
already paying for public schools and
the state should not have to divert uh
money from public schools which is
already inadequate money I might say um
and and uh share some of that money with
uh parochial schools and other religious
schools um so I think that the second uh
principle really is tied to what I just
mentioned and that is that this state
constitution requires State of New
Hampshire to provide an adequate
education for all children in New
Hampshire in adequate public education
and that is what the state uh attempts
to do uh by funding public education and
you know we all pride ourselves in New
Hampshire uh you know every Granite
Stater uh feels Pride when we see the
national reports come out and New
Hampshire is very high up on the list of
states that provides an excellent public
education but uh we shouldn't undermine
the funding for that public education in
fact we should probably Beef It Up and
um so again I ask you to itl this bill
for this and other reasons and I thank
you very much for allowing me to
speak thank you very much Mr Barnes are
there questions for the
presenter I see I see uh re leus has her
hand raised okay re like
this yes I have a question he was
talking about that nobody had referred
to the word separation of church and
state and I'm wondering where he sees
that in either the federal or state
constitution well it is uh taught in
every civics class in America I believe
um and and I've been uh um mock judge on
a mock uh not a mock Court a um the We
the People Civics education program in
the state for many years and uh high
school students are certainly taught
about the separation of church and state
and the place it comes from is The
Establishment Clause and Supreme Court
decisions uh
over Century or so uh that have uh said
that the establishment cause can be
violated if the state uh gives Aid to
religious
schools that sort of puts a thumb on the
scale of the State uh it's not obviously
not even close to literally
establishing uh a a state religion but
it does give State support to people who
belong to particular religions and I
would say that you know the the
religious schools that are getting uh
the federal money they require their
students uh to attend uh classes well to
attend chapel and to to attend classes
on uh religious Doctrine and uh maybe
religious history and I frankly I like
to learn about all of those things
myself but but uh
there there is an indoctrination goes on
and U in in addition to building the
playground uh which uh the first Speaker
talked about so the Trinity Lutheran
type of case uh and
Espinosa those are uh perhaps different
but I don't think they extend all the
way to providing uh State funds to all
aspects of religious schools including
uh the requirement of chapel and
religious classes and that is Under The
Establishment Clause that to answer your
question
again uh are you you still have your
hand raised are you all
set yeah I'm all set um I I had comments
on that but I I can't do that now okay
okay ref you have your hand up
M gotta unmute yourself yeah thanks
sorry Mr chair uh Mr burn um I didn't
notice any do you have additional
testimony in print that we may be able
to get or did I miss
that uh I'm sorry sir I do not but I
would be happy to submit some and I will
uh do so I'd appreciate that thank you
Mr Mr chair thank you Mr Barnes thank
you sir Mr Barnes I have I have a
question for you if um we have a a
student uh in uh public education here
in the state and off to go to a a school
which is so-call private religious
school however the classes he or she
takes are mathematics and English
language arts that type of stuff and
chemistry and there's no mention of
religion ideology at all uh do you
object to that type of uh
support well I think that the Supreme
Court has uh in uh has has talked to uh
spoken to that a number of in a number
of cases over the last hundred years and
uh yes I mean the court has made uh
findings in actually a case I litigated
a long time ago um that that went up to
the court as uh Felton against agular um
which was overruled uh a number of years
later and did allow Title One funds
Federal Title One funds to be uh
provided to students in parochial
schools um but in the record of that
case there is a lot of evidence of um
all of the religious schools and I was
at the depositions of I more more uh
Cardinals and and Bishops than I have
ever seen before uh and they all
admitted that there were there were
crosses in the in the school buildings
which they took down when the federal uh
inspectors came around they the students
were required to take Chapel the
students were required to take uh
religious doct
classes um and uh I can't remember if
they were required to take uh religious
history classes as well but they
certainly at least were uh en encouraged
to that was part of the curriculum would
be to uh basically steep a student in uh
Catholic Doctrine and that's great uh my
first wife was Catholic I I have
no uh problem with Catholic Doctrine
being available and taught uh if people
want to send their children there just I
don't think the state of New Hampshire
or any state or the federal government
should have to pay for it with our tax
dollars which already are not sufficient
to provide a fully adequate education to
students in the public schools and and
the state has devolved a lot of the uh
funding for education in the public
schools to loc local uh municipalities
and uh towns so it's the local property
taxpayer not even the state that is
funding providing the funding that we
have for public education and we
shouldn't take even $ one dollar away
from that thank you very much Mr Barn
bars excuse me are there further
questions
yes any question yes um thank you for
taking my question Mr barns um are you
aware that in uh public high schools
they do have uh classes that focus on
religions around the
world I am aware that many high schools
do have classes on religion I believe
that they are uh not mandatory classes I
believe that they're offered as a choice
for students and I would take the class
myself I I think uh it's it's great to
take it but um that is not the same as a
religious school which uh is mandates
that the child goes to
Chapel on a regular basis if not every
day um that the the child takes
mandatorily uh takes horses in religious
Doctrine um to give me the choice of
attending also a course that expands my
Horizon to uh many many different
religions around the world as you as you
ask um that's a very different
thing thank you very much are there
representa mof then represent Howard
thank you Mr chair thank you Mr barrence
uh M Mr bars I'd ask have you ever had
any concern about secular Pro ing taking
place in public
schools secular
prizing no I'm not sure what you mean
sir I my my experience with Public
Schools both for myself and my uh
teaching or speaking uh at schools with
with children who are students and also
my son's education I uh don't have any
uh sense that there's any secular
prizing you could clarify what you mean
I I I'll speak to
that uh well to to amplify my question
Mr M I what I was picking up on is is a
concern of course about religious
schools uh and mandatory religious
classes which you you refer to and the
concern that that that some folks have
is that in the public schools that there
are many examples of of Educators uh you
know speaking to values or promoting
values that are often in in conflict
with the values of the parents of the
students so uh again my my question
simply was uh I I understand your
concern about secular schools uh
promoting values and not being funded
for that reason and and thus my question
question to you simply was uh are you
similarly concerned about uh teachers or
Educators with captive
audiences when I say prizing I mean you
know advocating or promoting certain
values uh in the public school uh venue
and I'm hearing that that's not a
concern of yours is that is that
correct uh well not that's not exactly
what I said uh first I said I don't know
about any body uh
proing doing any secular prizing as in
demeaning religion or suggesting that
there's something wrong with people who
are very religious or partial somewhat
religious um I don't I don't have any
experience with that goes with that
going on but I certainly agree with you
to answer your question I would be
concerned um if teachers were making
students feel like they shouldn't uh
celebrate their religion um uh my
experience actually is that the public
schools have reached out and uh made
children feel good about uh exercising
their particular religious values they
uh invite uh my son's uh Jewish they
invited him to uh bring a manora in
Hanukkah he's you know the one of two
Jewish kids in the class and and
uh uh they invited him to present that
they had a you know
student from other
religious backgrounds and the school
loves to loved to
share have the kids share their uh
traditions and and religions with uh the
class so um I don't think there's any PR
what you call secular pral typ in going
on but if there were yes I would be
concerned about it and the way you
framed it at the very end was whether
I'm concerned about teachers with a
captive audience as you put it uh
promoting values um is uh I'm not sure
where you're going with that but
certainly uh teachers should not be
promoting any religious value and you
know the separation of church and state
is intended to be for or against
religion it it's uh the state should not
promote Catholicism or protestantism or
Judaism or Buddhism or Islam the state
also should not promote uh atheism the
state should uh leave uh people to
exercise any religion they want to and
to not exercise any religion if they
want to uh and in terms of teachers
teaching values promoting values I I
just have to point out that yes that is
one of the purposes of public education
is to teach values we want people the
children as growing up in America to
learn to be good citizens to understand
democracy and and the right to vote and
um uh values like uh loving your fellow
men and women um we're all created in
God's image is something that is pretty
uh much a value of of every religion I
know about and uh while it's not those
values are not promoted I don't think
should be promoted as a religious tenant
in schools the value of loving your
fellow human beings is something and
being part of the community uh what it
means what law means uh your rights and
as well as your respons responsibilities
you have responsibilities to obey the
law so there are a lot of values uh
democracy uh hope hopes to flourish uh
from our schools
uh uh teaching uh students to be members
of uh of our American
Community thank you thank you very much
thank you very much uh thank you you
willing to take one more question no
you're you're good repres
oh I'll take as many as as you want to
ask chair speak wait okay are there any
further questions uh Mr
Barnes not seeing any Ken thank you very
much Mr chair and members of the
committee thank you so much for uh joing
me up thank
you yeah you have a question now um I'm
searching for context Mr
uh a lot of our Pres
ERS are not really identifying from once
they come or where they are or who
they're
[Music]
representing okay I I I hear what you're
saying so what we'll we'll ask is that
at at the beginning of very presentation
with the individual who testifying
please uh uh give your your who you are
and and where you're testifying from
place and if you're uh testif on behalf
of an organization would you please also
you know indicate that Mr chair may I
just um answer rep allard's question um
up until this
point
um pretty much everybody has been
representing their themselves themselves
um with the exception um of
Representative Tim Horgan he indicated
he was representing his district the
other Representatives did not identify
their District they representing
themselves so um up until this
point uh represent I'm sorry Mr Bob Dunn
is uh from the Roman Catholic bishop um
Roman Catholic Church of Manchester so
um just to clear that up for you thank
you okay okay do we have any other folks
that are yeah uh we we have um Mr Bob D
as I said I believe he is the bishop in
the Roman Catholic Church of Manchester
go ahead Mr Dunn good morning uh thank
you Mr uh chair and members of the
committee I'm Bob Dunn uh I'm not the
bishop um I'm representing the bishop
I'm the director of public policy uh for
the Roman Catholic dasis of Manchester
and it will come as no surprise to you
that I'm speaking today in support of
cacr I I know it's been a long heing um
and representative cordelli and attorney
Smith have eloquently and and completely
addressed the history and the legal
context in which this cacr comes up so I
I'm not going to go through all of that
again I just want to uh mention two
things um first off um the uh the case
that representative Lynn talked about
that um wa state of Washington
ministerial training case is a case
named lock versus
Davey and that case was discussed in EP
Espinosa and in fact it was put forward
as a defense by the Montana Department
of Revenue in that case and the Supreme
Court ruled that uh that that lock case
did not apply in ESP Espinosa that the
real issue was and I'm gonna just read
the sentence here from the Espinosa
decision uh where the court said that
the no Aid provision by bars all Aid to
a religious
school simply because of what it
is um and so uh Espinosa again is really
dispositive and I encourage everybody to
to read that case um the New Hampshire
Blaine Amendment does exactly what the
Montana Blain Amendment did it bars all
Aid simply because of what the school is
and as Espinosa makes clear that
inescapably violates the uh free
exercise
clause now the second question um came
up earlier should this be repealed um
and uh as a number of speakers have
mentioned uh it it it absolutely should
first because it invites uh litigation
and the alternative is sort of caseby
case litigation but I'd suggest that it
be repealed simply because it's the
right thing to do why would we leave it
in it's a relic of a different time in
the body politic and uh and in the
church too I'd add uh about a third of
the students in the diois and schools
are
non-catholic and I very much doubt that
was the case back in
1877 um now to wrap up I guess I would
say that I know among all of us uh uh
that are participating in this hearing
today we have a lot of differing
opinions about whether it is advisable
for the legislature to provide public
funds to religious schools and how if at
all that should be done but that's not
the question here the question is
whether there can be a categorical ban
on that ever
happening and I'd respectfully uh
contend that the US Supreme Court has
answered that question uh and so I'd ask
you to vote a to pass on this cacr and
thank you for uh considering our point
of view and thank you for uh your
patience uh throughout this hearing I
know if we were all at the lob uh again
this would be the time of year where
everybody's walking around very blur and
and uh that is especially true in this
uh very unusual year so thank you for
your patience and your
consideration thank you very much uh Mr
D you got that parly right we're not
walking around but we're sitting blurry
eyed looking at
these so are there any questions from
the committee here U Bob Dunn from the
arch dasis representative Woodcock
representative Woodcock yes thank you Mr
chairman thank you Mr D for taking this
question I just want to refer back to a
comment you made for some clarity you
indicated near the end of your um
discussion that currently about onethird
of the students in the dasas school are
are non uh Catholic uh my question
following up to that is are are those
students required to take courses and
Catholicism and are they required to
attend chapels in those schools I
believe that the answer to both of those
questions is no
um uh I will double check on that and if
for some reason I have to correct that
I'll let you know but I am uh virtually
positive that that it is the case that
they do not need to do those things
thank you Mr D thank you Mr chair are
there further questions uh Mr D I have
one that has maybe several questions
within uh first of all during this uh
pandemic that we're in has the arch
dasis seen as an increased enrollment
within your school population and
secondly are your high schools
accredited high schools and if so uh
what type of Standards do they meet the
same standards of regular public high
schools or are your standards
different um I think again um I I will I
I don't really want to speculate I I'm
not the director of uh the schools but
um I believe that uh every single one of
the school schools is approved uh as a
private school by the New Hampshire
Department of
Education uh and that may well be
another difference between the Catholic
schools of 2021 and the Catholic schools
of
1877 yes thank you thank you very much
and what about your enrollment do you
have any understanding of the enrollment
question I asked whether oh yes I'm I'm
sorry um yeah I I I don't know um I can
get you that info I I know that the
enrollment as of
September was
um was a little over 5,300 students um
I'm not sure what it was in September of
the previous year so um I I I couldn't
tell you right now as I sit here uh
whether there was an increase or
how significant that increase was I
think that there was an
increase
than thank you very much Mr chair and
thank you very much Mr dun for U um for
testifying uh this morning just a quick
question um following up on on on what
representative lad was asking you in
terms of your schools compliance uh with
with State um um public education requir
requirements I was just wondering if you
could comment a little bit on compliance
with um federal and state statutes
statutes for special education and
non-discrimination yeah
I again I think our school person would
probably know that a little better but I
I think I I I'm pretty confident in
saying that that we comply or our
schools comply with all of the
applicable federal and state statutes
um so uh I um you know I I'd really be
kind of going beyond my area of
Competency to talk about that in any
detail so just just a followup on that
and um and if and if you could um
provide the the committee with with with
you know this this information but
particularly particularly with respect
to special education and public schools
requirement to provide a free and
appropriate um um uh public education to
uh uh to students with uh with
mechanisms for due process in place um
uh do do your schools currently provide
those services for I mean special
education services with due
process what's your point of order uh my
my question my point of order is we're
discussing cac3 and now we're very into
uh policies of special education in
Catholic schools I don't understand the
connection between cac3 and that
question I I think where ref s luno is
trying to lead to is that uh in regard
to special education whether they're
they're providing that service or not
providing that service I think that's as
far as it should go yeah that that's
that's all I'm trying to get at Mr CH I
can I can absolutely get uh answers to
those questions um I would add though I
I want to underscore that um this is
exactly the sort of discussion that I
think would take place with respect to a
legislative determination about whether
um public benefits should be afforded to
private or to religious schools um again
this the the Constitutional Amendment
and is is really around the question of
whether there is a categorical B that
that can be in place so um I I don't
want to lose sight of that fact but I
will um I'll I'll I'll follow up um with
the answers to the those questions
terrific thank you Mr dun thank you and
could you follow up on this one too uh
back when we were dealing with SB 1993
several years ago it was uh communicated
to us over in the governor's chamber
that um all your high schools and our
Das our neas approve the New England
Association schools and
colleges okay
accredited okay um M
has oh I'm sorry you have your hand up
yes I do thank you Mr chairman um just a
a point of or or a question of
clarification for the um for the witness
um Trinity High School I believe is a
diine high school is that correct in
Manchester it is um and I'm looking at
their course list and it says amongst
required courses are theology intro to
Christianity intro to Christianity the
Catholic faith and Morality In the
sophomore year intro to Christianity the
cathol Catholic faith and morality um it
goes on would these be the kinds of
courses that representative Woodcock was
asking about earlier as required um
courses in Catholic
theology well I would say probably you
know generally speaking at least they
they
would okay thank you thank you mull has
represent Mullen you have your hand up
uh I do thank you for uh taking my
question just to assist uh Mr Dunn um in
the parent student handbook from Trinity
High School there is uh a paragraph that
follows the mission statement and it's
entitled the Catholic nature of Trinity
and it reads this uh non-catholic
students are welcome to attend Trinity
High School with the understanding that
all and that is underlined of our
students are required to take the
religion classes prescribed by the
program of studies and graduation
requirements and that all students are
required to attend all religious
exercises so I just um I just bring that
up so that Mr Dunn doesn't have to kill
him himself looking for that information
it's in the parent student handbook oh
great okay and I'll I'll confirm that
with the uh with the folks in our cathic
schools office as well thank you thank
you very much are there further
questions for Bob
dun not seeing any hands thank you very
much thank you we have any further
peopley on this so we've now come to the
close of those wanting to offer
testimony on cacr three um we have the
number of folks uh that went various
ways yes okay what we have here did you
want to
read okay go ahead
bar support 46 opposed 236 testifying
13 hey
what you want me to repeat it yeah go
little please oh support 46
oppos
236 testify
13 thank you thank you very much so with
that I'm going to close the hearing on
cacr
3 the next hearing we have when the next
hearing supposed to start 11 11:15 so
we're gonna take a break until uh 11:15
here that's a half hour uh and we're but
we're g we'll come back at uh 11
so we'll take a 15 minute right
[Music]
pleas um Mr chair what what are you um
the next hearing doesn't start till
11:15 so what's the 11 o'clock I may
want to take up a bill to
exective any idea what that might be so
that we could uh chat in advance yeah
think we're going to be looking at the
uh the tal the bill that representative
Ma has the survey for giftedness oh so
so Rick um could could I could I get a
point of personal privilege on that um I
I was hoping i' I've been talking with
representative Oliver about an amendment
and um and uh just in the last couple of
days and I want to talk with you and
Mike about it as well um
could you uh could you give uh represent
m a call uh right you know right now and
up to and so um then we'll have a little
bit of more understanding because I
think he also has an amendment I don't I
think that was sent out yeah yeah yeah I
I I got that and I actually built it off
that okay give him a call okay and and
and chew on it with him we'll talk about
it 11 o' Mike Mike can you um can you U
um email me the number the best number
to call you on tell you right now what's
that you can tell me right now sure yeah
491 say it again it's on my uh my
profile
491 yeah 491
0553 0553 Mike I'll call you in a minute
thank you all right
thanks
yeah
for
e
mine say
11 okay um are all the committee members
back in their seats and ready to move
on can you hear us out there
okay I see that okay
um we're not going to be acting on that
particular bill I I mentioned at this
particular moment um but we do have uh
three bills that I communicated with
represent Myer during the break with and
the first bill is going to be uh 257
that's referencing political asy in
schools and our call upon cordelli to
make a motion thank you Mr chairman uh I
would like to move that we uh retain
House Bill 257 prohibiting public
accuracy in a public schools and I'll
second that okay we have a motion on
table to retain uh bill um 257 as
political advocacy in schools M motion
made by represent cordelli and second by
represent Hobson Discerning discussion
from either of the there's no
discussion is there anyang hang
on yeah thank thanks Mr chair why
wouldn't we just itl
this you're addressing that to whom to
you the bill um has some positive intent
in regard to um
uh the issue that we talked a little bit
about earlier uh in some of the other
discussions
ccr3 my concern is that if we have it
moveed Forward at this particular moment
in the first year of the
BM there's GNA be an offl discussion on
the house floor and this bill could end
up taking us another hour an hour and a
half on the house floor and I don't know
if that's a priority of the education
committee to have to be discussing that
and probably that discussion will go
well beyond members of the education
committee okay Mr Mr chair I appreciate
that um but but uh I I don't see the
positive any positive elements of this
bill so uh I would you know I I would
certainly put out there that that if I
were to vote to retain it would not
because it would not be because I
recognize anything positive about the
bill but only to avoid um prolonged and
unnecessary floor
debate we we noticed a lot of confusing
language within that bill uh a lot of
these need
clarification uh and it's it's just not
ready to move forward I'm just very
concerned about what we're going to end
up with when we get into the next
session this bill will just suck the air
out of the
room so with that if there's is there
any further discussion
Madam clerk would you please call the
RO this is a motion of
retain on House Bill
257 representative cordelli yes
representative B yes representative
Aller yes representative lakus
yes paron me she said yes yes okay
representative M yes representative
Hobson
yes representa and yes representative
for yes representative Lon yes
representative sod yes representative
Miler
yes Luna no
representative Shaw no representative
Cornell yes representative Tanner
no representa Ellison
yes M yes represent l no represent
Woodcock
no
15 sorry I represented lad yes and I
miss represented bone no you got oh
okay thank you
155 okay the next bill which we had that
I communicated with
uh repr Miler was 215 and um I indicated
that's a bill it's my bill one which
references School contracts with
privates uh much of the language within
this is already in statute there's
already reference to Independent Schools
and and in language and it deletes one
of the old terms which we have um I'll
get to that bill here and read that term
to you um I just don't believe the bill
is needed after we had
hearing just trying to reach down get
here okay the bill basically did any
school district may make a contract with
an academy that's already in law a high
school that's in law I inserted in their
independent school that's already in law
elsewhere or other Private School
located in uh another state and raise
appropriate money to carry the contract
in effect um private was added in there
however we also have these Interstate
agreements already which are if there
approved by the other state then it's
it's acceptable so I don't think that
bill is needed I'm even I will make the
recommendation that this bill be
it is there a second second second okay
I heard a second from representative B
and representative Allard mam cler take
your
pick is there any discussion on that
bill not hearing any discussion mam CL
would you please call the RO to itl HB
I didn't find a
porn this is on
HB
25 and the motion is
itl representative cordelli yes
representative B yes
representative
Allard yes representative leus yes
representative Mett yes representative
Hopson yes representative Andre Yes
represa Ford yes representative Leon
yeses sod yes representative Miler yes
represent lumo yes sh yes represent
Cornell yes repres Tanner
yeses
yes repr Mullen yes L yes repr wood
yes 20
consent consent okay yes
yes yes also yes consent okay consent by
somebody out there in c space right I
know who who who made that consent
motion
over there start yeah yes okay U the
next bill which I talked with M about
was
um let's see HP
234 freedom of
speech uh this is a bill that we heard
uh was presented by representative
Alexander as as far as I'm concerned has
many fine considerations and points but
however after hearing from Ron Rogers at
the
University uh many of these issues have
been resolved and according to fire we
now have schools which have gone from
red or yellow to Green uh all our state
schools and so um if there is anything
that has to be done in regard to this it
needs to be carefully thought out and
not done through a boiler plate type um
act such as this so that's why um do we
get a motion I'd like I'd like to
recognize uh represent for a motion
thank you Mr chairman I would move that
we retain House Bill
234 and represent Mett do you have I'll
second that okay we have a motion made
by represent cordelli and second by
repres reprentative Mett to retain uh
this bill HP
234 can you speak to your motion please
than thank you Mr chairman uh yes I I
think that there are uh some possible
benefits to uh certain parts of this uh
bill um I also want to look more at the
suggestions submitted by uh Shannon Reed
of the community college system um with
the suggested modifications that they
make um so uh I am not ready to uh get
rid of this bill entirely I I think that
um it uh could use more uh work and uh
review uh before we uh have a different
U motion on the
bill is there further discussion
represent
Cornell I just there's so much much
that's already been done and that isn't
needed I I don't know why we wouldn't
itl it and if somebody has more
concerned bring up another bill that
concerns their what they have concerns
with rather than just retain this bill
that really most of it is unnecessary
and with fire and and according to
the people from the University and the
community colleges have already been
taken care of
representative uh
Tanner uh thank you chair for taking my
uh comments this is the second at least
the second time since I've been on the
education committee we've had this bill
we retained it in fact uh representative
mafin and I were on the committee the
last time it was retained and you know
it it was a for me a simple matter of
getting the community college and the
university system together together with
the people that had a problem and
resolved that problem and that's why now
they have a green rating from fire um
because the problems were brought
forward and and corrected and I think
that's the New Hampshire way rather than
legislate um a bill that was obviously a
a almost a a national Bill model um you
know in New Hampshire we sit down and
and try to resolve things with without
um a lot of laws hopefully and that's
why I would rather see this bill ited at
this time thank
you
Le um thank you Mr chair I I understand
that a lot of progress has come forth
with previous bills on this issue
however one of the spee uh one of the
sponsors of this bill was very recently
on college campuses and saw a continued
need for this I believe that we can
improve this bill um and I believe that
the right thing to do for our college
students is to retain this and come back
with something better next year because
there are still opportunities for
improvement and this can be better
fine-tuned so that we can address what
still is an issue here in New Hampshire
and congratulate our universities on
what they've already done so
well further
discussion yeah I would concur with the
uh previous speakers we the the higher
education has done a good job in
addressing the issues that came before
this Committee in previous sessions and
I think uh I think it telling this is
the appropriate thing it's a recognition
of the work that they have done
notwithstanding uh representative lon's
concerns uh I think they've done a good
job and I think fire was very fire was
the outside group that come came in was
very critical of how the institutions
were working and for them to give their
green light to this I think it's
significant and that's why I think I
this should be the itl did not retain
thank you further
discussion represent bone thank you if
we itl a bill then we can't bring it
back next year but for retaining and
with the co going on not that much being
done on college campus so we don't know
if they're gonna keep so I think by
retaining
it we let the university system no we're
still watching them and we'll see what
happens next year so retaining I think
is the best
motion thank you representative uh luno
thank you very much Mr chair um I I I
was actually gonna sort of jump on
exactly the same um point that
representative B uh just made but I I
think based on the comments from that
that other people have heard with
regards to to the the significant amount
of changes that would be required um uh
to somehow uh uh you know alter this
bill to improve upon the work that the
um or build upon the work that the
university system community colleges
have already done that would be an
entirely new bill and this bill could be
itl and and a new bill could be
reintroduced next year without uh
without stepping on um stepping on this
so I I think support the itl uh don't
don't don't retain a a really a bad Bill
when uh when something new can can can
completely be you know introduced uh
next
year okay uh it appears that there's
some communication coming to me from
from people in the committee on that
we're right about 11:15 when we should
be starting the other hearing here so
I'm going to allow uh one anybody that's
previously spoken on this uh I'm not
going to recognize and I will allow
those that haven't spoken on this I will
recognize represent wood thank you uh
chairman lad U I just want to I would
concur with the the idea of itl and I
would follow up on representative Bon's
comments where he said we we should tell
UNH and the state agency that we're
still watching what this does says we
did watch and they made the changes and
want and where where we should be uh I I
think that's that's that's exactly where
we should be I is buil for that reason
they've done what we've asked them to do
thank you okay great we have we have a
motion on the table on I'm GNA ask the
the clerk to call the RO the motion is
to retain 234 relative freedom of speech
and Association on college
campuses representative cordelli yes
representative bone yes representative
Gard yes representative lakus yes
representative Moet yes representative
hson yes representative Andress
yes representative for yes
representative Leon yes representative
sod yes representative mil no
representative Luna no representative
Shaw no representative Cornell no
Representative janner no representative
Ellison no Mullen no representative Le
no representative Woodcock
no
11 lad yes
119 okay with that we are retaining
234 we're going to now uh open up the
hearing uh on our next
bill that
388 388 oh that's
mine okay 388 so I'm gonna have to hand
the G over to represent
cordelli thank you Mr chairman um I will
open the hearing on house build 388
relative to changing a pupil's school or
assignment because of a manifest
education hardship and I'll call upon
chairman lad to introduce the bill uh
thank you very much for the record
I I come from Hil New Hampshire and I'm
here today we're just starting just
started
hear I muted that was Miler okay and and
I I'm here to speak on HB
388 this bill is a bill that is uh been
heard many many many times in front of
the education committee here and we
started with this uh several years back
and uh we're looking at this bill in
terms of definitions and much of the
language here um uh includes the two
definitions that we had developed in
previous years uh the best interest of
student M find and manifest education
hardship that is also defined but in
looking at this bill we need to
understand both of these definitions
because it's a two-step process that we
have here for establishing a manifest
education hardship manifest education
hardship is when there's a difficulty a
difficult situation for a student the
the student has that bottomline choice
of working with Administration school
boards Etc to have another placement
I'll get into that more thoroughly but
to understand manifest education that
definition needs to be looked at it's
it's documented uh evidence or a
condition that is either physical mental
or
emotional and that a student may have
and how that is detrimental to and
impacts the students academic
achievement and and and growth and such
condition must be severe pervasive or
persistent so as to interfere with a or
limit the ability of a student to
receive an education so that's manifest
education and the best interest of
student we we've identified in the past
discussions and work study groups that
um there are occasions when a parent
comes and says my child's having
difficulty in this school in this
present environment and it's not in his
best interest to remain in that
particular assignment or
placement so there's a process built in
this uh legislation where parent can
come and and speak directly with the
superintendent and request uh uh that
action be taken to assist their child um
the superintendent receives that he must
respond with it 10 days of notice that
he's going to have this meeting with the
parent and a decision is made if the
superintendent decides there is U
evidence that this child needs
uh and in the best interest the child a
different placement or support provided
he or she may do so by either
transferring the student to another
assignment within that school uh
transfer to another school Within School
District or seek transfer outside the
school district uh where this the
student is not living to a nonresident
school district that might be a public
school academy or other approved school
not in that District of residence that
is a change that we from previous
discussions where it's before it's been
um in in in another um let see how did
we in another uh
I'm trying to look through my many
agenda here another SC
in what we have inserted here is another
approved school which means another
approved school which could be anywhere
from a private school to a um a a public
school uh
so if in fact the parent uh does not
like the decision of the the
superintendent there's an appeal process
um if the superintendent decides in the
best interest there is a viable option
and and should be pursued to put the
child in another Resident District
oftentimes in past years this has been
done uh where school superintendent have
agreements between each other I know up
in my neck of the woods Plymouth and
hail did have an agreement where kids
were placed from one school district to
the other school district and the costs
of that tuition were waved by both
superintendents because it went to two
ways Transportation though is the
responsibility of the
parent um if in fact the uh nothing is
accomplished in the best interest of the
student according to the parent the
parent has an option then to appeal that
process and request a hearing with the
school board which has to occur after um
a notification is provided within a
15-day period of time and basically the
same process occurs there where
documented evidence is brought forward
and resolutions made by the school board
as to whether they're going to
CLI in another school uh or outside the
district within the district
Etc um there are certain conditions that
must be met before a a change of school
assignment can be made subject to a the
parent petitions for change or consents
to the superintendent's recommendation B
superintendent deter determines that
this is in the best interest of the
child see school board a Board of
Trustees approved the sending school and
the school board that they're within
approves this as a receiving school does
not have to approve it that student do
not attend and there in this previous
law there's been a cap um of the number
of kids which can leave a particular
School District it's 1% of that
enrollment ADM enrollment and and and uh
and 5% Max from a School within that
District so that's basically where this
bill is going now it's now change the
legislation to re or other approved
school not in the district or or
residents and and uh that provides an
option to send the student to approve
schools uh and there's a number we got
in that discussion a little bit this
morning I'm not going to go there again
right now um so um that concludes my
testimony
and I'm willing to take any questions
thank you uh representative Miler thank
you Mr chairman and thank you uh
representative lad so we've worked on
the Manifest hardship over really the
last three sessions I've been in the
house here my understanding is that the
language for the issuance of the
Manifest hardship that's not in question
here the only thing that's in question
is what's in bold which deals with the
approved school is that is that correct
that's
correct um okay see you know just as
test I I might repr luno is is question
okay I'll let representative luno ask
the next question yeah so so
so Mr chair and and um and
representative Myer uh I I actually sort
of had the same
understanding of it that that you just
laid out until I looked at the bill um a
little more closely and on on um line 11
it talks about how RSA 193 colon 3 Roman
1 through Roman three are repealed and
reenacted so that means that every all
the text in here can be new text whether
or not it's bolded or not and I'm not
even sure what the Bold text means in
here because if it's repealed and
reenacted normally that comes through as
straight
um non-bolded text it's only when it's
amended is it bolded text but I'm I'm I
just pulled up um 193 colon 3 and wow I
mean we did a lot of work on this um two
years ago and and I I I can't really say
to what extent this change um totally
upends the the existing content but this
isn't this isn't minor tweaking
um
um so I I don't so I I guess um um
representative lad was this what you
intended to
do the okay the intent of this bill is
try to put forward what we had um
previously
uh had resolution I believe there are
some changes to what we had previously
uh it it just doesn't say another school
it says An approved
school right but it doesn't even follow
the um I mean you can take take a look
at the current 193 colum 3 Roman 1
through Roman 3 and it's a it's a total
rewrite
um and even even the definition of
manifest educational hardship is
completely different from the definition
that we all agree to I think in
a wasn't it a a a really strong vote
last two years
ago me that I don't think anything we've
ever done to this has been
changed the definition for manifest
educational hardship is
changed that that's exactly right we we
have never when we first started working
on this and we came up with this
definition manifest education hardship
working at that time with Barett
Christina and I don't know if he signed
up to talk here or not but we never put
that into law yeah it it's it's it's in
law it's in current law we did that two
years ago not in the placement that it
is right
here definitions are now at the top here
as
definitions I get that but it's a
different definition I mean you and I
sponsored the bill two years years
ago raised his hand is there a question
here yeah I'm sorry I know this is sort
of uh this is sort of getting at was was
this what the what the what
representative wad intended to put forth
because it just looks very inconsistent
from what we what we did two years ago
and even the the um the the the way it's
bolded but it's repealed and reenacted
it's it's
um it's very odd I I can respond to that
and then I think bar might want to go
forward I had about three or four
different eight house bills which dealt
with manifest
education and I don't I can't recall
which one was submitted to um the
legislative services to do this year my
intent is that we had moved forward with
a process uh last year and the year
before that and of course last year
because the omnus bill uh we we uh it
never I don't believe it made it then um
I do know that there's one process that
I am concerned about is that there needs
to be a hearing process available and
there I think this does speak to the
hearing process for a parent to have
access uh if they're to an appeal
process um on on the U to the state
board but I believe that's already L and
at this time I guess uh I'd like to
suggest as person is presenting this
that this is a bill that needs to move
forward uh whether this is the right
version in front of
us I can't honestly tell you
yeah I I I think you might want to
re maybe re take a look at it and and
schedule a new hearing on it um I think
we can have a hearing and then of course
that that's something that can be
modified by by a work group you know
it's I don't think we have to reschedule
another hearing and there's a way around
this are there other questions um did I
see representative
wood thank you represent cordelli I I
had two the first one was representative
I mean luno answered that if this is not
the bill we're actually going to be
working on I don't know why we're having
hearing on it if the bulk of the
language in the bill is not
italicized um and we're just looking at
that part the second part was was more
specific uh so that was a question but
representative lad appears to want to go
forward with the incorrect information
the the second part
was represent lad if this would um
apparent requesting a change due to
manifest be uh reasonable if they
believe that their school is only
teaching remotely and they want them in
in face-to-face learning or vice
versa would that meet the definition
this is uh this is just a totally new
circumstance from where it was um I know
that there was an amendment that came
forward that represent luno and I put
together as I'm just trying to jog my
memory here where we had put together a
bill which we all basically I I think
supported that's where we need to be um
I would like very much to just you know
have an opportunity here after we get
this thing introduced and that's all
we're doing right now to the committee
um to then uh bring forward and quite
frankly I have not put much time into
this at all uh it's something I recogn
need to be put forward that that we we
see as a priority um it needs to be done
correctly I agree if there's any
differences uh then we need to you know
settle those amongst ourselves it's a
good candidate for a
study a further study together followup
represent Celli yes just the
representative L just the second part of
the question um under the manifest
definition on the document we have now
my question is would and I'm just asking
Rick because I'm not sure where it would
fall if a parent wants to contest or
request a manifest because they not they
don't believe the child is is learning
in the remote they want to go to a
school that has face to face or vice
versa would that be construed under this
definition I don't think so and manifest
education hardship is that second step
which and if you read that carefully
that definition and that was a
definition that was uh put forward by um
all of us working Cooper
together and it says uh in reading that
such condition must be severe pervasive
or persistent so as to interfere with or
limit the ability of student receive
education um and we're looking at the
the physical the mental the emotional
condition of the student um now
obviously if a kid's not in school and
if they're in a remote situation for
example my own grandkids right now
they've been out of school for two
consecutive weeks without even being in
the confines of the building now if that
were to continue I could quite well
argue that that is a a severe impact to
that child's growth and learning um so I
I think that every Situation's a bit
unique and that uh I think the
definition that we we struggled to
develop here and this is the
definition that I believe that working
with the school boards Association who
came up with uh and we all concurred
to uh please inform me that it's not and
and U but and to interpret this this
goes all the way back to the Lisbon case
years and years ago where an individual
was looking to find a school that can
provide the academic program they wanted
it may not have been offer know that's
not a manifest education
AR that's
not thank you Mr chair um represent
Mullen thank you representative cordelli
I didn't expect you to go to me so
quickly um in that definition of
manifest hardship representative vad uh
the word so is critical because in the
definition that we adopted and went into
effect September 27th of
2020 the definition says that the the
condition must be so
severe that it negatively impacts blah
blah blah blah blah through the rest of
the definition in the current definition
of the bill that you proposed the so
moves from so severe to the position
where it is uh it has to be present so
as to influence so in my mind the
difference there is that if something is
so
severe it sort of highlights the degree
of impact but if it is so as to
influence then that's a lower standard
at least that's how I read it I can
respond to that when when our our folks
over in legislative services are writing
bills for us uh
oftentimes a little word like so can be
moved around and that really impacts um
and when you put a word like so in front
Okay now try to Define so where is that
boundary where's that Line in the Sand I
don't and so it's I I think it such
condition must be severe pervasive or
persistent so as to interfere um right
but that's quite different than so
severe that it impacts the performance
of one has kind of a superlative nature
to it well respond to that we're getting
into lawyer talk right now and and that
you know reasonable unreasonable you
know all these I totally I I do not uh
for a minute representative lad think
that somehow or Another You plotted this
positioning of the word so but I do but
I do think that it was part of part of
that was the discussion last time around
was so robust because we were looking at
things like
that so
uh if we need to change that so so
change
it work I just feel that we need to have
a process that's more definitive than
what we have in statute right now uh
this process of math education came out
of years and years ago with No Child
Left Behind that's where all emanated
from and the initial wording that we had
came out of uh Cambridge
Massachusetts and and we have modified
it over the years of our having
discussions uh what I I would like to be
able to do is find out where that
wording is that we had the maybe the
luno laad lad luno and and and to get it
in there and and move this thing for
that's that's my only de it's in statute
so it won't be hard to find it yeah it's
okay
um yeah so just to clarify
this uh represent Vlad your intent from
what I understand what you're saying is
not to change what was agreed to last
time and as in current law your intent
of this language was to merely add the
boldfaced items that are in that are in
in The Proposal is that
correct the intent that I had was to try
and move forward the language that we
had discussed now I'm looking at what we
have here from legislative Services when
I was looking at this briefly after
taking the kids to basketball practice
last night or game up in St J at about
9:30 and 10 o'clock at night I I you
know quite frankly I looked at all the
different bills we had plus this one and
it would became confusing okay
so that we have a manifest education AR
bill that uh
reflects what we had worked on and I
don't know now if we're going back one
or two or even possibly a little over
two years we've been on this thing I
just want to put it there okay so so uh
just for clarification then my
understanding then is that prior to
moving to executing this particular bill
that there will be further
conversations uh in the interim to try
to clarify exactly where the current
statute is in relationship to this
particular proposal is that correct
that's correct I okay thank you we put
some the the stuff in there okay thank
you respond to you Mel I'm not satisfied
for putting a definition mixed into the
bill itself into the content I'd like to
see a definition that we have in there
right now moved underneath definitions
so it can be quickly found and taking
what we had in that original Bill the
one that that the Luna lad had and we
talked about manifest education but it
embedded I would just prefer to see take
that little poop out and put it
underneath a SE say definitions so it
can quickly be found I'm not looking at
changing content at
all point of order um yes point of order
thank thank you very much representative
uh Mr chair and uh representative lad um
the reason I'm calling a point order on
this is is because I I don't think what
we've got in front of us is anywhere
close to what to what representative lad
intended in fact even in representative
lad's um remarks introducing the bill he
talked about the importance of having an
appeals uh process through the State
Board which exists in EX in in current
law because of the the lad luno U bill
that went into effect two years ago this
bill takes that out out so I I I mean so
just at the simplest levels um it's it's
missing critical components and and
representative lad I mean I think all of
us on the education committee uh two
years ago remembers that hearing it was
one of the best hearings we had um uh
with very robust discussion um people
were were were really involved in
putting forth a um really solid piece of
policy having worked on it for a long
time and um and I you know I I I just
don't think we're going to be able to
have a hearing on on on that given the
um given that th this I think is just
really
um you know I'm I'm there's a lot of
bills and I know think sorry about
that
um but I think we may want to just sort
of get
this get this amend ended and conduct a
a a new hearing on it so that we can
have that same sort of robust um
testimony and participation that we had
two years ago are there other questions
from the committee Linda Tanner has her
hand raised
and um thank you I I totally agree with
uh both representative Miler and
representative luno that um we need to
you know revisit this um knowing the
things that we do know my initial
question was simply uh about the the
bold face and that was uh when it says
other approved schools not in the
district of
residence um we have schools approved
for tuition purposes schools approved
for uh attendance
purposes um we have schools that may be
approved under a learn
everywhere um and we might have schools
uh in Canada just across the border or
um schools in another state is that is
that what you're opening this up
to is that your
intent is that a question to me yes um
yes you're the even thought i' been
opening this up to a school in
Canada
um um
it's it's it's
a I'm looking at
uh the word it says before in another
District or other approved school not in
the district I have there right now of
residents so it really opens it up to
being able to place a child in another
school it could be public or private
that's how I see
that right but it's an approved school
and what I'm saying is under the doe
laws
there's approved schools for tuition uh
approved schools for attendance and
because it's another school it simply
says another approved school not in the
district of residence could that be for
example if you were in the top part of
New Hampshire and you wanted to go to
Canada could you put your student there
um Switzerland maybe if you wanted to do
there or uh could you choose California
or you know um it seems to be really too
wide open for me but um I was wondering
if that was your intent or that was
something an unintended consequence of
that approved School means approved by
the department or approved locally by
your local school board uh for if you're
a tuition program uh school which we
already have in law so it's referencing
approved as we have in current statute
uh so we have no no approve approval for
schools that are in Switzerland or or
for mod Academy in uh Saxon Ser Vermont
or whatever uh unless Vermont Academy
happens to be approved by Mount ker then
I imagine that might be but that would
only be applicable to Vermont or me um
just as a followup on that um if I could
um what about the learn everywhere
program where uh approval for programs
there uh might include a
school learn everywhere program is
approved by the State Board of Education
that's not approved by your um your
local board but uh that would lead to
credit for
graduation I I don't think that that's a
that's a program available for specific
courses it's not a school it's not
designed to be a full run School Al it's
an alternative program so I don't think
that even relates to this we're talking
about a free school learn everywhere
program is not a
school thank you um representative
lakus yeah yes I was looking back at uh
last year we had
1282 um which we took to interim study
we had I haven't gone through the whole
things that we did last year so this uh
wording was based on that but yes we did
go and we worked with Barett Christina
and we all worked together and we came
up with something wonderful it did and
we passed it but it never went into law
because it got put into a big one of
those big bills and got defeated so it
is not current law so what we need to do
is find and that's why you're finding
such a difference when you're looking up
what's in current law and it doesn't
look like this it's because it didn't
end up in current law it we all agreed
but it never um made it all the
way it went to the Senate got put in a
Big omnus Bill got to and that got
defeated and so it's not lost so we are
still back to where we were and what we
need to find is which I have not found
yet I'm still looking a copy of uh the
agement what we finally ended up with
with baric Christina and everybody
working on it together and start from
there and I think that was the intent
was to do that plus but just add these
approved schools I looked at this
wording and this wording is the
same as uh 1282 which is what we started
with and I don't I haven't yet found the
wording that we ended up with I'm still
looking for it was there a further
question representative no I just wanted
to um explain because that seems to be
what the confusion is um a point of
order yes repr luno yeah so the Manifest
education hardship bill from from last
session made it into house bill 1558
which is the Omnibus Bill that was
drafted in the Senate and it was um um
it was um passed uh I believe on our our
last session day and signed by the
governor um I can give you the date on
that signed by the governor I think it
looks like um on um July 29th so it is
in
law thank you
I remembered it thank you any further
questions from committee
members uh seeing none um uh Barrett
Christina has his hand raised did you
want to hear from him okay Mr Christina
I'm gonna um promote
you maybe you can end all the back and
forth um good morning uh members
representative cordelli chairman
cordelli thank you for uh recognizing me
members of the committee uh bar
Christina executive director New
Hampshire school boards Association
I I'm not sure I had testimony prepared
I'm not I'm not sure where I can go with
that now um indeed we made comprehensive
changes to the Manifest educational
hardship statute RSA 193 col 3 last
years um representative luno mentioned
it was House Bill
1328 that bill um passed this committee
unanimously the vote was 18 to zero um
it then moved to the Senate um where
obviously got held up due to to covid
and and all that sort of stuff but um as
as representative luno did mention it
was embedded or included in House Bill
1558 the Omnibus Bill if you go to RSA
1933 on online you'll see um that the
the date of Effectiveness or the
effective date um was September 27th
2020 so
uh presuming that this is the bill um
that that was intended to be put forward
this is a language that was intended to
be um put forward um and hsba um um
would oppose this uh we spent probably
three or four years as representative
lad um spent working on manifest
educational hardship I believe it was
two years ago there was a lad lumo luno
either bill or amendment that we thought
we had gotten through and it was in the
Senate and I think we found some
language that was either contradictory
to one another or or changeed some of
the intent of the statute so that's the
that's the version that died I believe
um two sessions ago but last year we
made significant changes um I thought we
were good with it it was unanimous um we
had good conversations within the
committee we in included a uh a
definition of a manifest educational
hardship um to help parents sort of
navigate the system and understand what
it is and as well to provide some
clarity and guidance to to school boards
and superintend and and the State Board
of Education as well too um I I one of
the concerns um that nsba has with the
the the the the proposed language um the
definition of manifest educational
hardship in the bill on page one lines 6
through1 is is different than what's in
current law um uh you know the the as I
believe it was um representative Mullen
you brought up the place of the of the W
so the other significant change is the
current language um for the current
definition of a manifest educational
hardship means a student means that a
student has a documented hardship in his
or her current educational placement and
that such hardship has has a detrimental
or negative impact on the students
academic achievement or growth physical
safety or social and emotional
well-being the hardship must be so
pervasive and persistent that it
interferes with or limits the ability of
the student to receive an education um
this definition on line seven um where
it says that the documented physical
mental or emotional condition is brought
on by his or her current educational
placement that's a significant shift
from what the pre the current definition
stands for that definition in the in the
bill seems to be blaming the public
schools um for the Manifest educational
hardship and we know that that's not
absolutely not the case um some of these
are are some of the Manifest educational
hardship cases deal with
Transportation um which is not the
school's fault um some of them deal with
family circumstances which is certainly
not the school's fault uh the other
problem with um going through the bill
where where it's you know approved
School approved school um that seems to
be the gist of the of of of the change
to open up manifest educational hardship
where the parent can apply a request to
send their kid to a private school um
that was not the conversation that we
had last year when it came out of this
committee
unanimously um we purposely intended to
keep this and I say we I mean
collectively nhba all the stakeholders
and this committee purposely decided to
keep manifest educational hardship
within the public school realm when we
had a bill I believe it was two or three
years ago um representative lad when you
first introduced the changes to the
Manifest educational hard ship statute I
believe in 2017 or 2018 sir I remember
you sitting in that chair and you saying
this is not intended to be a school
choice bill this is intended to provide
clarification to the to the current
system and provide definitions and help
clean up the process so parents can have
a better understanding of what it is and
the bill last year House Bill 1328
embedded in 1558 does that the other
logistical problem with the bill um I'm
jumping to page
three on line 11 where it talks about
computation of tuition so presuming that
the intent were by adding um proove
school is is to open it up to to to
allow to private schools this says I'm
again I'm on page three line 11 it says
um I'll start on page 10 excuse me uh
the middle of the sentence the district
in which the child resides shall pay
tuition computed as provided in RSA 193
colon 4 to the district or approved
school so I'm going to jump to 193 colon
4 this is one of the last sentences I
won't read the whole statute except
under contract the liability of any
school district under this section for
the tuition of any pupil shall be the
current expenses or operation excuse me
shall be the current expenses of
operation of the receiving district for
its Elementary or junior high school or
public school of the corresponding grade
at estimated by the State Board of
Education for the preceding year so the
language in the bill does not correspond
or line up with RSA
1934 1934 talks about public school
tuition this bill opening up manifest
educational hardship to private schools
I don't know if the State Board of
Education has any determination or any
say or calculates or gathers what
tuition is for private schools so the if
you're going to change this to open up
provisions manifest educational hardship
to include private schools you have to
find some other way other than 1934 to
determine what the tuition is going to
be because 193 col 4 does not fit into
this um the other aspect and I believe
um I forget representative Tanner it may
have been you you had some questions
about approved school and and what does
that mean there are two types of private
schools that can be approved by the
Department of Education there's well
different kinds of private schools I
should say there's a two approval
processes this is in Department of
Education rule
400 um you can be approved for
attendance which basically means your
building your facility meets fire codes
and safety standards has nothing to do
with academics or curriculum performance
assessment anything like that and then
there's also Department of Education
rule
44.2 those are um private schools where
the Department of Education um does
actually approve their program I don't
know if they approve their their
curriculum and assessments the same way
that the that the department does for
public schools um and there is some
minimal talk if you will um
44.2 um the nonpublic school shall
demonstrate the relationship described
above as follows um a list in and and
description of courses offered for
credit um noting whether it's required
or elective art music drama dance so on
and so forth um but guess the bigger
point is that that program approval when
the Department of Education is approving
the program of a private school um that
44.2 is about a page long maybe a page
and a half long the approval process for
public schools is about 80 pages long um
so it it's certainly not the same as the
approval that's required for for a
constitutionally adequate education
which is which is required under the New
Hampshire Constitution um I think those
are nsba
um comments I think that concludes my
testimony um the definition
significantly changes um I haven't gone
through I believe it was representative
Miler you mentioned how repeal and
reenact as follows and that sort of um
created some of the confusion I excuse
me I haven't done a deep dive into
current law and to see like what may be
o inadvertently omitted if this is not
the proper bill before us but um but
anyway I guess the bulk of my testimony
is this body spent the better part of
three or four years working on this bill
or on this issue and hsba was happy to
help because we know it's an important
issue for kids across the state um but
to bring this back the following year
when we just made significant changes to
the law that was um by partisan um I I I
don't think is is prudent for this
committee right now so um we would
certainly urge you to um to oppose our
I'm sorry to find um House Bill 388 and
expedient to legislate and with that I'm
happy to answer any questions
thank you um any questions from the
committee seeing
none thank you
Mr thank you all you all right next we
have an Marie
Danfield uh and Maria I promoted you
welcome to education
again okay good morning um well
afternoon so my name is anarie Banfield
I am an advocate for rights and academic
excellence and
education I come here today uh I was
actually asked by a parent to read her
testimony so this is not my personal
testimony this would be from Shannon
bushard uh I did ask her to make sure
that she emails the Comm committee with
written testimony so that you have it I
also would like to mention that I just
received her written testimony so I ask
you to bear with me as I go through it
uh as I'm actually reading it um at the
same time as as you are or as that
you're listening to it Miss as you um go
through that could you try and summarize
best as you best you can well I I could
except that I I haven't gone through it
and I don't think I would be able to to
do that um it's not too long but I do
think it's important to listen to her
personal situation especially in light
of what you're speaking about right now
if you've worked on this for three to
four years and this is what you came up
with and we have parents that are still
uh having issues or problems then I
think that this would be something that
you should probably consider as you look
at this new bill so I'll make it as
quick as possible I don't think it's
very long but uh I'll begin with um
Shannon buard uh my daughter was
harassed repeatedly at her school after
winning the Manifest education Hearing
in August I was excited that my daughter
would have a chance to get a new start
in a new Public School
I have now been working since the end of
August to try to obtain a new district
for her to attend the problem is this no
school will accept her at this time and
manifest educational hardship law does
not protect my child in making this
happen I was foolishly thinking if I had
the hearing in my favor that we would be
able to start fresh since the hearing in
August I have read the Manifest
education law over and over and over and
it tells no way that any public school
has to accept a hardship case this
leaves the parent and child possibly
having to remain at the district where
the bully harassment has occurred my
daughter and my family have had extreme
anxiety at not finding a new school the
meh was WR as written does not allow her
to choose a new public school because
you are at the mercy of the receiving
school superintendent they are told to
look at the best interest of the pupil
no one is looking out for the best
interest of my daughter this is not
right
this is unfair and we owe these children
who have already re received so much
trauma in their District to not have to
worry about who will allow them to
enroll these students awarded the meh
did nothing wrong yet the schools made
are made to allow allow them and they
are getting punished again I'm sorry I'm
trying to read it verbatim they are
already ha they already have to leave
the district that the bullies caused the
hardship with my daughter does have
friends she will be leaving behind she
is getting punished as well as we are
because of the fact that she has been
harassed I am responsible responsible
for transportation yet the two closest
districts won't let her attend not only
did I give up free Transportation yet
now I have to drive farther to find a
school willing to accept her the cost of
time and fuel on us through through
nothing in the me has nothing in the meh
law is protecting us am not getting the
promise that the law is intended to help
with this is extremely damaging to my
own relationship with my daughter I have
never broken a promise to her I can't
find her a school I worked really hard
putting together my evidence to prove
hardship I told my daughter if it was
awarded she would never have to deal
with going back to that school I
promised her I thought if I did
everything right the law would protect
us my daughter would finally have the
education she was promised with a free
appropriate public education my daughter
would be able to not become physically
ill thinking of going into class I have
had to obtain a lawyer just to be
granted a hearing in front of the school
board as our Superintendent at the time
denied me saying me was not intended for
special needs students he also said his
answer was Final we were granted the
hearing in August and I was finally
allowed to go in front of the board and
prove her educational hardship I
honestly thought finally getting a
hearing the law would protect my my
child the law has failed us again the
receiving superintendent also has
no also said no to taking a hardship
case and also not allowing us to
allowing us to go before the school
board the way the law is written she is
able to do this as a re the way the law
is written she is able to do this as the
receiving District must accept the
superintendent decision is final the meh
bill bill has not allowed me to protect
my daughter
we are halfway through the school year
and my daughter is still learning
remotely at the same district everyone
agreed is a hardship the lack of support
for families after winning the me is
huge I'm almost done the law was
supposed to allow for a school change I
have reached out repeatedly to my home
district for any support they can give
me in securing a school for hardship
transfer they leave it up to the parent
to figure it out the law does not make
the school where the hardship occurred
be responsible and helping secure
another replacement the law as it is
written does not help parents with their
children I do not believe anyone had
those intentions when it passed my
daughter is still in the district that
caused her so much hardship I am still
coming up against the fact that no one
can help me not even this the State
Board of Education and finally the law
was written as it's written gives
parents the false impression that if
they find their child to have a hardship
because of the harassment of their child
with their home District that there are
supports in place to help these supports
have failed us I hope that everyone can
see this in support making this be what
it was intended I was intended it was
intended to help parents and their
children that is not what I have found
with the meh law at all um that is her
testimony I want to thank you I'm
obviously not going to be able to answer
questions for her uh personally but I do
hope that you will consider this going
forward with this
bill thank you uh
mfield um you have one more yes we have
Jody Underwood she is an elected
official representing herself in support
of the bill and she has requested to
speak for three
minutes go ahead Miss Underwood thank
you thank you it actually stopped the
zoom thing while you said my name so I
didn't even hear it how about
that yay Zoom I mean zoom's been great
um okay uh for the record my name is
Jody Underwood I am Vice chair of the
Cen School Board um I do support the
idea of the change um to change the
options for reassigning a student uh
under manifest educational hardship but
um I also am not happy with the other or
approved school not in the district uh
wording um approved and a lot of people
have talked about this already so I'll
try not to repeat repeat anything um
it's the word approved is just not clear
um and um Mr Christina pointed out the
two definitions that the state has uh
approval for program and approval for
attendance um I'm actually um happy that
representative Tanner talked about other
possibilities because I think those will
also fall in in line when people are
starting to challenge this unclear
language if this Bill does pass the way
it's written um I think that programs by
approved by learn everywhere might
actually be the most appropriate for a
particular child and that is the point
of manifest educational hardship is to
you know get the kid out of a bad
situation um and goodness and and Ann
Marie's testimony just now also brought
up a really interesting point about
there's just no teeth on the other side
um and to go back to in earlier thing
yeah public schools are not required to
accept every student that is placed
there and in this case that is one of
them but that's a separate issue um so
how do you how will it be figured out if
you just leave it with the word approved
and the way we do it is we ask a judge
um but anyone familiar with the court
case that led to the passage of the cin
Bill a few years ago knows that's an
invitation to disaster the judge in that
case declared that the phrase including
but not limited to actually meant
limited to in order to rationalize the
result that he wanted which turned out
to be forbidding school districts to
tuition kids to private schools under
manifest educational hardship exactly
the bill we're talking about today so if
common completely unambiguous English
words like including but not limited to
can be twisted this way in court what
chance do ambiguities like not in the
district and approved have of being
interpreted to mean what what they were
intended to
mean unless amended to make its intent
Crystal Clear uh HB 388 practically
guarantees more court cases and
therefore more ludicrous judicial
decisions please make it clear or do not
pass it thank you thank you mwood um any
questions from the comme
members
none thank you very much and
um we will We were supposed to have um
Carl lad and he's not there um
occasionally Mr F yeah not there yeah
okay thank you
um thank you very much we'll end the
hearing on HB
388 and um Mr chairman would you uh like
to call us back at 1:00 yeah that that's
the time I think we're supposed to be
starting back yeah so yeah so what we'll
do Mr chair what were the numbers on
that on that signing in ETC we haven't
seen that me to read it okay so we have
four signed in in support 120
opposed one neutral and we had four
testify um yeah four
thank you thank
you okay is there further
um um discussion or anything among
committee members okay what we're going
to do is we're going to Jour here for
the next 50 minutes and come back at 1
o'
oh
but you totally lost me on your
present
he
have
aand yeah
I'll I
think
okay I think it's been
my never
mind down one so thank you anybody yeah
thank you bye
bye oh
thank you want me to um clck a window
anybody these masks you know are
just a couple weeks okay I think we're
ready to go ahead here uh with the
afternoon portion of today's meetings we
have uh several bills left for a hearing
the first of which is HB
455 this is an act relative to the
ability of a parent to enroll a child in
a public school of their choice um
parent Boots the bill is representative
cordelli represent Celli are you ready
to present I am thank you Mr very much
uh for the record representative Glen
cordelli representing tuon burough
molten burough and sandwich in the
beautiful Lakes
Region uh HB
455 uh replaces the current open
enrollment
statutes this provides for uh basically
public school choice our parents and
their
children uh currently we know that there
is zip code discrimination and wealth
discrimination based on where you can
afford to buy a
home uh this legislation tears down
those artificial
boundaries between uh
districts we don't restrict people uh to
certain Geographic areas in other
aspects of daily life uh you can go to
any car dealership any drug store any
Supermarket that you like but you can't
go to any public school that you like
right
now parents want the best education
possible to meet their child's
needs there have been instances in this
country where parents have been fined
and sentenced to jail for not being
truthful about their address all so that
their child could attend a better Public
School
how can we let that go on in this
country just doesn't seem
right uh I wanted to just go through the
bill for a moment if I can um and point
out uh certain Provisions within
it um on uh the first page uh down at
the bottom uh 194
D2 um every school district shall adopt
policies
and excuse me policies and procedures uh
to implement the provisions of this uh
chapter and the department shall make
information available to the public
about the options um in the public
school
system over on page
two a parent May enroll their child in
any public school or public Academy
without regard to Residents or District
foundies they uh wish if they wish to
attend a non-resident public school they
have to fill out an application to the
receiving
district and no receiving District shall
reject the application based upon grade
level age level pupil need areas of
academic Focus aptitude academic or
athletic
ability U this is different from the
current open enrollment statutes where
you can uh reject students on aptitude
and other
criteria the district receiving students
may deny the applications for several
reasons one a lack of space or capacity
or two the pupil is under suspension or
expulsion in their resident District in
those cases the receiving District would
not have to accept an application
um if there is a number of applications
that exceed
capacity uh they would start a waiting
list for those
students um if the parent feels that an
application is uh denied for uh a
nonvalid reason they can appeal to the
State Board um in accordance with 541
the standard appeal
process the department shall develop an
application for uh
enrollment and the State Board shall
adopt
rules uh the I know this will come up uh
the receiving District shall not be
required to provide
transportation uh to the public
school um for children living outside
the district the parent May provide
transportation to a specific bus stop in
existence for that receiving
District um and um down on the bottom uh
State education grants shall follow the
pupil so uh it's a
very simple bill I think um and it
uh
accomplishes my goal of in putting it
forward that being to
allow children to go to the public
school that best meets their
needs and I thank you Mr chairman thank
you very much are there any questions
for repres pelli Mr Miler I'm
sorry thank you Mr chair and thank you
represent cordellia for taking my
questions this may be a simple bill but
it has major ramifications for public
education and rather than going through
all of the issues that I have with this
I just have really one question and I'm
referring to page
one line
25 my presumption is the way this is
written is that no school has an option
not to participate in this program when
you say every school district shall
adopt that means that the state is
mandating that every school district
regardless of size or location must
participate in this program is that
correct uh basically the state would
become an open enrollment state for
public schools yes thank you very
much other
[Music]
questions thank you very much um um Mr
chair and and thank you very much
representative cordelli for bringing
this one forward um
I'm could I just put your attention down
to uh page one lines 22 to
24 and and actually I want to start with
line 24 the um the end of that sentence
end reads that does not require
non-resident pupils to pay an
application fee or tuition um does that
um sentence apply to the any the the any
public school up on page 22 the public
Academy on 22 and
23 and the interstate compact on line 23
does does that qualification that does
not require non-resident students to pay
an applic application fee or tuition
apply to all three of those um entities
I I believe so um uh the uh the intent
there is that there not be a separate
tuition charge to the parents um outside
of the normal um has
still so follow up on that yes so so
then if a public school on line
22 does have a policy for non-resident
pupils to pay
tuition um then that would exclude that
public school from Roman one is that
correct I I think uh line 24 or would
apply in that um uh they would not be
allowed to charge a separate tuition fee
for
non-residents okay um
thanks wel questions represent lady you
have your hand go ahead thank you Mr
chairman just a a couple of quick things
um and and you know I'm new to the
committee so I don't know have the Deep
background that you all do but on uh
page two
line
10 um where it's uh the following
reasons can a receiving District can
deny lack of space or
capacity who defines capacity how is
that defined Can a district for example
simply say we don't want to go
above I'll just make up a number 12
students per per teacher and that is our
capacity or is there a formal or legal
definition of capacity in existence
right now there is not a formal
definition right yes than fire code you
know things like that building codes
thank you um and just a quick followup
and this is where again Mike lack of
experience on this um comes into
play I'm looking at the bottom of page
two there the funding section so would
the only funding that comes with the
student from outside the district be the
state funding is that it is that the
only funding that would come with that
student so let's say the student goes
from I'm just going to make up from
Jaffrey which is the Jaffrey ringe
district and goes to uh the conal
district is the only funding that comes
with the student the state funding is
that it
corre pardon I'm sorry correct so just
final followup then so the idea here
would be that the local taxpayers I know
you said that you want to eliminate zip
code discrimination but would this not
then put extra burdens
onto the taxpayers in resident within
the
district because they would have to
support the education of students who
are not whose families are not being
taxed um in support of that
District uh it seems that
um uh
some districts might uh not want to lose
District uh lose ex me lose enrollment
um this is a means for them to
uh gain enrollment in a time when
they're um losing enrollment uh possibly
um I don't know it seems like they maybe
some that want to have it both ways they
want U more funding when they lose
students and more funding um when they
gain students as
well but just for clarification here
just so I know I understand the the the
receiving District um could potentially
incur costs above and beyond the state
adequacy and and you know any any other
state monies coming but they would have
no ability to raise that money from
through property taxes on the family
that is sending the student because they
non-resident of the district
correct that's the way the bill is laid
out currently thank you thank
you thank you Mr chairman um and thank
you rob cordelli for taking my question
I have a couple very similar I'm getting
a little more
confused if I am in a poor school
district for example
Berlin and I decide under this rule I
can go to Molton borrow which is a very
affluent School
District um and my mother I'm a student
my mother goes there to asby every day
for work so I'm leaving a what average
$7,000 a year uh cost so we get $4,000
transferred from Berlin to molon borrow
but molon Bor cost must be in the High
Teens early 20s
so I think this following up on what
representative lay was saying so that
the residents of molon borrow who fund
that school and now going have to be
funding students that don't live
there would that be
correct like the only money that would
um uh go with the child would be the
state money right will fall so the only
state money though is the adequacy right
so if if molten bur cost 20,000 a year
to go to and Berlin costs whatever it
costs all they're going to get is to say
4,5 $5,000 to come with adequacy so the
deficit that $115,000 additional expense
in molten borrow the molten borrow
residents will have to pick up and pay
well I I thought that um when enrollment
increased um costs were variable but
maybe I'm wrong about that well it's t
it's like putting one in as you said
putting one in and one out it doesn't
matter much but the cost of the student
in Ran is that much more a second part
this this will allow um I just want to
make sure I'm right the CL ification if
I am a school district that's losing
kids because of enrollment and I'll give
you an example up
here Jackson is is bartett is losing
enrollment uh because youngsters are
graduating um so therefore our
SAU uh is losing income because it's a
tuition school so that means we could go
out and advertise for students to come
from other districts to come to our
school we have low
enrollment Cor I don't see anything in
here that prevents um
advertising or trying to attract
students okay so you competitive pitting
one school district against another so
the last question R Celli back back in
my district
again because I'm just trying to
understand non-resident right now I'm
trying to make myself clear
too okay so if I may the last question I
hope the Conway school district has some
students that go to the fryberg academy
in
Maine so under
this and and we contract with them so
under this bill does that mean more
students could leave Conway and go to
the fryberg academy and what what would
the pay how would that Finance
work um
Conway district has it has an agreement
with fber that they sent some of the
Conway the kenet students to fryberg
Academy yeah some of the sa un9
correct um I don't think that would be
not a u going to another New Hampshire
public school but that would be
um uh I think a different situation and
I have to find out more about the
Contracting situation here I think
okay because you were talk you're
talking about if if as as I read the
bill if this if the school system
already has a contract with that
District Interstate com pack Interstate
compack
yes so what would be the answer there
I'm sorry I missed so under the
interstate Comm Interstate contract if
sa9 already has a contract with Fook
Academy would this allow more students
to go to Maine and be funded by New
Hampshire I I think would be the same
they would be going under the contract
yes whatever Provisions are in the
contract they
would go under the provisions of the
contract that you have with fryberg
Academy okay so so the tuition would go
so basically students could transfer
from Conway to under this and enroll in
fryberg okay you have an existing
contract yeah we do okay thank you thank
you Mr chairman thank you represent
Celli repres
Tanner so uh my question is about
changing schools multiple times during
the year um
either uh can they do that either
because they find out it's not a good
fit for them or the school finds out
that it's not a good fit for them
or um I really want to play field hockey
in the fall and Newport has a really
good field hockey team but um gee uh
basketball season rolls around and
sunup's got the best coach and then the
spring comes and karge has a nice track
and uh I really want to run track and
field so can I under this uh provision
um because they can't discriminate
against me because of Athletics can I
just uh go from one school to another to
another um or and how how does that work
with payment and signing up and
everything else so you're thinking that
student might want to go to a certain
School regardless of Transportation or
anything else based on um what season it
was what sport was uh being played at
that point absolutely absolutely either
that or even if for example I go to I go
to snipy and it's a small school and I
find out that gee I'm I I don't fit in
there either so in December I decide I
want to go to karge and then I find out
I don't fit in there so maybe I'll
try um I don't know Proctor
Academy um I would have to look at the
athletic association um agreements I
don't know if that is legal uh
oh students would be enrolled well it's
it's legal it's legal if you're enrolled
in that particular school abely um to
play uh for that they can't deny you
extracurricular activities um you know
it could be the math team I want to do
the math team at karge the literary Club
at snipy
and um I don't know um play pickle ball
over at Newport um can they Chang
schools multiple times during the year
under
this and how does the money roll student
families can currently move from one
District to another during the school
year multiple
times yep so but they're not moving so
they're moving the child and there's a
money issue here that's how does the
money issue move with the kid with the
student no different than if the family
moved well yes it is because in this
bill the money moves with the student so
if a student goes to sunap the money
comes out of karge and goes to
snipy um and they're there in the fall
for maybe 4,000 or $5,000 but then does
snipy have to pay Newport pro-rated if
the student moves to
Newport to play
basketball I uh I I don't see it any
differently than if the family
moves during the course of the school
year and I I could come up with 101
hypothetical situations that uh I think
are strictly
hypothetical these aren't hypothetical
students move people people move because
they don't fit in I
mean um and wouldn't it be nice if we
allowed students to move elsewhere if
they don't fit in the school that
they're in yeah that would be great and
that's really the whole purpose of a lot
of the choice bills that um we are
seeing didn't get
it thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative cordelli for uh taking my
question so um am I correct when I read
this bill that um a school district like
Bedford that has in fact successfully
charged students tuition to
attend uh would you believe the faculty
who want their kids to uh attend Bedford
schools while they work in Bedford
actually have to pay upwards of5 $16,000
a year if they want their kids to attend
am I correct that under this plan you
would the the school district would no
longer be able to charge that tuition
um I
um uh I would like to examine that
situation further I hadn't considered um
the uh scenario that you bring up okay
all right um could I have a follow-up
question um I I did notice that also a
provision in the bill uh says that if a
parent a parent has to provide their own
transportation but the bill says that
they can basically drive them over the
Town Line and drop them at the closest
bus stop or whatever an appointed bus
stop and then the school will provide
the
transportation from that bus stop to the
school is that a correct assumption
yes okay and is there any kind of um
provision
for limiting the number of kids on a
particular bus route or would we leave
that up to the school
districts um that would be a local
decision I
think okay thank you you could look at
capacity it could be capacity of a
bus yeah I I just um I had some
questions about that because when
somebody else asked the capacity
question about a
classroom um there didn't seem to be an
easy way to determine what the capacity
in a classroom was going to be um and I
just wondered whether or not that would
also apply to
Transportation thank
you I might add to everybody out there
that they do have a capacity in terms of
our school building a program they take
the square footage in a room and you
know many of the rooms are built around
let's say a th000 square feet in the
elementary school and they have so many
square feet that are allocated for
students so you can develop capacity
that way most districts though are are
the pupil teacher ratio the PTR varies
significantly from let's say a
Manchester I'm sure it's well over 20 25
to smaller school districts where it may
only be
10 so um but there are some uh capacity
limits set within School building Aid
and the formula for construction
schools okay further questions I
represent pel represent representative
lad I just have one followup yeses yeah
just the FYI um and follow up on
representative mullen's comment uh the
teacher tuition piece is relevant in the
Conway District as well we have te
because Conway has like I would assume
Regional Schools as well Conway for sure
where blet and Jackson make up part of
the SAU but they have different tuition
uh fees and cost from each town so
teachers that work in Bartlett and live
in Conway similar to sus point if those
teachers want their youngster to go to
the botet school with them in the
morning for all kinds of reasons they
have to pay the full tuition so so
that's that was same as the idea of the
the tuition for low other schools suck
up the cost but that was the it's
relevant that happens all over at least
I know what does up in our area of the
country just the point of
interest thank
you forther question
Mullen has her hand
up look I was trying not to be greedy
the last time around and Rapid Fire
questions so I paused um so with the
back to the capacity issue so if we have
a situation where let's say we start a
school year and the capacity in an
Elementary classroom is 25 students and
the town has filled 20 of those seats
according to this bill if I'm correct
representative Cordell five seats would
then be up for application for people
who were
non-residents so if we fill those five
seats with
nonresidents and then 17 new second
graders move to school over the course
of the school
year what do what happens then it I know
the bill said that you shouldn't have to
Prov provide additional
staff but what if the enrollments go up
H how H how would we deal with
that that is a a question um that uh I
think we uh could look further at in
relation to the language and
here further questions repres
cellan
not seeing any thank you very much uh
represent okay next we have um jim
oconnell I've promoted him uh welcome to
education go ahead please um thank you
um my name is Jim oconnell I'm a school
board member at large in the city of
Manchester I'm uh I'm here I'm opposed
to this Bill I'm here to speak on my own
behalf today um I thank you for um
having the opportunity to speak with you
all uh twice in one week um and uh so um
this bill um I I I think with with great
respect to the sponsor of the bill I I I
believe it is ill thought true and uh I
think it's it's an idea that might seem
reasonable when written as a single line
let's have people let's have educational
be fungible and people be able to go
wherever they want and that that just
simply doesn't match reality so some as
an example um if we look at the
contributing towns issue we've talked
about some of the issues in other towns
in contributing towns the town of
hookset sends students to Manchester
right now and Manchester charges for
that um they send large numbers of
students to Pinkerton Academy I I think
they probably spend send maybe a couple
of hundred who are paying perhaps
between 12 15,000 or something like that
right now my understanding is that those
revenues would all go away on this on
this road it this this bill as it stands
would play Havoc with the existing situa
the actual situation on the ground the
reality is we have if people send kids
to schools we fund them through property
taxes the property taxes are paid by
Property Owners when I sell my house in
in Bedford and move to Manchester um
there's an accommodation made through
the real estate transactions besides how
my taxes have dispersed between those
two towns there is no process by which
tenants in those buildings or or that I
could swap that those taxes through
Treet towns it'd be anal analogous to me
buying a house in Manchester in January
selling it buying a house in Bedford in
March selling it buying a house in
Tuftonboro in April and selling it again
and buying another house in conquer in
in in in in October and somehow we'd
like the school systems to work out how
the tax dollar should be distributed
across the schools in those districts it
is faral it is unworkable and ought to
be addressed before this bill goes
beyond where it is today um I don't
agree with the bill because what what we
ought to be doing I think is we ought to
be raising the standards in all our
elementary schools our middle schools
and our high schools in all public
schools we have looked at the funding
issue in the state we know it's
inadequate we know that it's inequitable
and uh and I I would love to see this
committee concentrating its efforts on
providing an adequate education to the
young people people of the State of New
Hampshire and uh and that's I believe
where we should start with with great
respect thank you for hearing me today
and uh I'd be happy to answer any
questions that didn't address the issue
issue in Manchester where we do have
people in different school districts
within our city um who uh so we see this
in microcosm and in our city but anyway
I I won't proceed further I'd ask you
not to support this bill and thank you
for your time thank you very much Mr ell
are there any questions uh for Mr oono
thank you very much thank
you okay next next next we have John
brano he is a member of the public
Pittsfield New Hampshire school district
he opposes the bill and says he needs
three minutes to speak welcome to
education thank you very much I
appreciate the opportunity and I will
take less than three minutes today I'm
the relatively new interim
superintendent of schools in
Pittsfield and I'm opposed to HB
455 I believe passing of this bill will
provide daunting challenges for
Pittsfield residents and taxpayers
including many Rural and property poor
communities the inequities that could
Foster have grave potential to create a
further divide of communities who are
blessed with more resources than those
that are challenged Ed by the economic
disparity for me this seems
like a challenge between the halves and
the Have Nots um I think there are a lot
of unanswered
question for example eventually how we
we plan longterm for the retention of
faculty and staff what about our
obligation to our most challenged
students what about special education
services and what do they look like what
about the loss of revenues from Grant
monies from students leaving the
district
um I encourage you to defeat House Bill
455 and I thank you again for the
opportunity I know you're very busy and
I appreciate it thank you very much Mr
BR um sounds like a hockey
player thanks John are there any
questions for
the thank you than you Mr chairman and
thank you uh for taking my question um
could you envision a scenario where a
student uh because there doesn't seem
any there's not really much left to the
receiving District by which they could
deny a student uh seeking to transfer in
but could you envision a scenario where
a student um transfers in from out of
district and then has to be sent out um
for special needs and special education
um hardship cases and that the and who
would bear the cost on
that was that a question from Mr
Graziano
yes I'm not sure um and that's why you
know I'm I'm here today I I would say
politely I'm confused I don't understand
it um and I think that those
unanswerable questions today
create in my mind the potential
disparity and the difficulty and the you
know inable voyages that we may have to
travel and I say may we don't know for
sure well thank you thank you very
welcome uh thank you very much are there
more questions for
John not see any hands about here um
thank you very much uh John for
presenting or for take the time today to
come before the committee thank you very
much you're welcome um do we have some
any yes uh we have uh Carl lad from the
New Hampshire school board a School
Association I'm sorry School administer
never
mind people
TI
administrator thank you wait welcome
welcome to
education good afternoon chairman lad
and members of house education for the
record my name is Carl lad the executive
director of the New Hampshire school
administrators Association it is a
mouthful um nhsaa opposes 455 for many
reasons it raises far more questions
than it answers it has the potential to
discriminate against families from lower
lower socioeconomic situations as well
as students with special needs will
widen the achievement gaps not lessen
them increase costs for both receiving
and resident districts undermines local
control and creates inconsistencies with
a number of statutes already on the
books um and it really appears to be
more of a national agenda than it does
uh New Hampshire
need in New Hampshire we already have
open enrollment statutes in
194-31 allows for students to leave
persistently dangerous schools we have
have our current manifest education
hardship law and the federal Essa law
section 1111 D1 school choice for
students attending comprehensive School
Improvement or CSI schools uh there seem
to be sufficient laws on the books for
families here in New Hampshire uh if
they are truly negatively impacted by
their local school district and some of
the most glaring questions that comes
out of this how will this legislation
affect long-term tuition contracts and
area agreements
representative cordelli indicated that
the contracts would be honored however
that's not what the bill says many
school districts have sized facilities
and staff based on contracts that have
been implemented and this legislation
would upend those agreements uh that
have been made and have been put in
place for over 60 years in some cases
and would really appear to
undermine many of the statutes already
on the book such as RSA
19334 and five I think that we really
need to be cautious about this the
biggest question is around special
education which um representative Le
just mentioned who's going to be
responsible for Education special
education services the resident or the
receiving District RSA 186 would
indicate that the resident District
would be responsible but who makes the
determination of services when
evaluations and determination of
Eligibility are required Which special
Education team has that responsibility
that's defined under Ed 1105 and
ed18 which district is going to be
responsible for developing the IEP as
defined in Ed
1109 for students requiring specialized
program which district must provide
additional funds to fund the program if
parents file a complaint which district
is going to be held accountable for the
findings the resident District which no
longer educates the student but
responsible for the funding
or the receiving District who's
educating the student if there are
monetary Awards or findings who's going
to be responsible for paying for them
how will Ida Grant allocations and
funding reimbursements under special
education Aid or Medicaid to schools be
decided is this really a choice
regardless of the law you pass receiving
districts in neighboring states are
absolutely under no obligation to accept
New Hampshire students unless there is
already a contract in place and what
happens to that
contract on page one lines 23 and 27
what's the definition of a program does
this mean a student could apply to
attend a school's Athletic program a CTE
program an after school program is this
like an alart selection that uh families
and students can just choose from
neighboring school districts for those
parents who can't transport their
students even across the line to to drop
them at a bus stop doesn't this
discriminate against them would the next
fix that we would have to face be
interdistrict Transportation or open
Transportation do receiving districts
have no say in who comes into their
Schools page two lines seven and eight
state that no receiving District shall
reject an application with the only at
caveats being lack of space or if the
student's under suspension or expulsion
if a school doesn't wish to participate
in this program and States annually that
they have no room does that satisfy that
provision who determines the space or
the capacity of the school the local
school district the Department of
Education the State Board of
Education if receiving districts are
only receiving the adequacy payment plus
any differentiated Aid doesn't the
receiving District then bear the
remainder of the cost of educating that
non-resident student would that not
impact the School District budget and
cause an increase in property
taxes there are many questions that need
to be answered just under the
implementation section on page two lines
23 to 25 state that the receiving
District shall not be required to
provide transportation it then goes on
to say that the district must provide
transportation to those students who are
transported within the boundaries who
pays for additional buses or bus stops
if
necessary on page two lines 31 to 32
state that per pupil education grants
shall be distributed plus any
differentiated Aid the differentiated
Aid was established to help Local
Schools provide programming and
resources for a population of students
who meet the statutory criteria not for
each individual student so as a
practical matter couldn't the loss of
students in the Resident District affect
the overall calculation of
differentiated Aid which would then
lessen the adequacy grant going to the
receiving District dist there are at
least a dozen more questions that I
haven't included in this
testimony this bill is fraught with
statutory inconsistencies and raises far
more questions than it answers I would
hope that if we truly wish to have a
serious conversation about school choice
in New Hampshire then we should convene
a study commission similar to the
funding commission to bring in experts
from other states who have some of these
policies in place already ready examine
the potential fiscal in uh impacts and
really look at um determining the future
of public education in our state
together rather than allowing National
think tanks and political ideology uh to
rule the day this is a complex
initiative when it's coupled with all
the other choice legislation that's
being proposed this session would
drastically change the educational
landscape in New Hampshire I've heard
some legislators indicate that school
choice is coming whether we like it or
not if that's true and this is to be the
future of public education in New
Hampshire and the nation that it should
be incumbent on all policy leaders to
look at this issue thoroughly
holistically and in context you know I
worked in Massachusetts which is often
heralded as one of the champions of
public school choice at least in New
England there was a very thorough
comprehensive examination of that policy
change all the stakeholders were
involved so that in order to make it
work and Achieve buyin and support all
the voices were heard and balances were
struck to make the system work to the
extent that it does I'm not supporting
the Massachusetts model in New Hampshire
but I'm not dismissing the notion
altogether either but I do think our
families and taxpayers deserve a more
thoughtful and considerate examination
of school choice before we careine down
this particular particular path thank
you very much for your attention and I'd
be glad to try to answer any questions
are there any questions for uh Dr Lad
represent M uh thank you Mr chair and
thank you Dr Lad for taking my question
it's my understanding that in
Massachusetts they've had a school
school choice program for over 25 years
and that many of the questions that
you've raised are currently in the
statute that provides Clarity on exactly
how this program could be implemented is
that correct that is correct and one of
the um one of the main elements that
came from um that school choice
discussion which was when Mitt Romney
was the governor of
Massachusetts um had to do with how uh
School District governance was going to
be handled in an era of school choice
and and how could you make that work if
you were truly going to make schools
compete with one another and you wanted
to use a business model then you needed
to use a business model so what happened
was the school board uh the school
committees in Massachusetts are
relegated to approving the budget
overseeing the budget and hiring the
superintendent that's
it all of the other decisions relative
to Personnel curriculum instruction
assess
all of those decisions are made by the
superintendent that's a very different
model than what we currently have that
and in order to make school choice work
that needed to happen um because you
needed to take out some of the
decisionmaking uh levels of authority I
don't see that happening in New
Hampshire so I I really think that that
creates a a real inconsistency with the
only model in New England that really
works followup please yes so you you
raised an interesting issue here and
that is where are the decisions made as
relates to dealing with education if I'm
hearing what you saying is that the role
of the Department of Education in
Massachusetts plays a much more
immediate and dominant role in education
policy than they than it does currently
in state is that correct that is very
true I I can um one of the ways that I
explained um the relationship with the
commissioner of Education uh in
Massachusetts versus New Hampshire was
if the commissioner of Education in
Massachusetts called me and told me that
I needed to do something I needed to do
it when the commissioner of Education in
New Hampshire called me as a
superintendant to tell me I needed to do
something I would tell him that I would
take it under advisement because I
needed to answer to my local school
board who set the policy and hired me
it's a very different it's a very
different setup there are and there are
hundreds of laws in Massachusetts that
have been created in order to make
school choice more effective and if you
want to take a look at the most glaring
difference it's the way in which
Massachusetts funds their Public Schools
as opposed to New Hampshire and that was
also part of that large discussion about
school
choice thank you are there further
questions for Dr
Lad not see any thank you very much
thank you Mr chairman welcome are there
oh I'm sorry I just popped
off yes uh we have Barrett Christina who
Barrett Christina from
the
association
go ahead
please good afternoon thank you
representative Hobson uh thank you uh
chairman lad and thank you
representative cordelli um I know you
have another bill I'm going to be quick
about this I think all the the concerns
n hsba has um with the bill were um
adequately and eloquently stated by Dr
Lad um and also members of the committee
um in their questions to representative
cordelli um basically touched on the
concerns that nhba has um in terms of
funding um you know it seems that we're
creating sort of a an inverse donor Town
system if you will where if kids from
Manchester leave to go to attend Bedford
that Bedford is going to be paying for
the for the education of of Manchester
students um a couple things that the
bill does not um address um that have
not actually been spoken on are capital
costs as well too um you know if if a
school district needs to bond um for
either a renovation or a new roof or
whatnot um the local taxpayers is going
to be paying for that bond to to to
educate the children from another
Community um which sort of the state
adequacy a is not going to come close to
covering um contracts uh tuition
contracts have been addressed um
capacity has been has been addressed um
you know and who determines what that
capacity is is it square footage or is
it what that local school district has
chosen um for their sort of P say uh
student teacher ratios within their
their Elementary School classes um I I
don't want to talk about much of the
bill um beyond that I I think all the
the major points and concerns on hsba
has have already been addressed but um I
I would like to say one thing
representative cordelli you've mentioned
zip code discrimination and I know
you've used that phrase a couple times
this session and and NH hsba agrees um
that there is zip code discrimination
throughout New Hampshire I I think we
disagree as to where that exists though
from nhs's um Point of View zip code
discrimination um with the Statewide
education property Dex and the way in
which we fund our Public Schools um you
know we know that Franklin and burlin
and Pittsfield and Claremont have a hard
time um and you know and we know in
Newport and we know if we look at some
of the assessment tests they're their
scores are not going to be as as high as
you know some of the towns um that have
greater property value so um you know we
do agree that the code discrimination
exists but again we think it's the way
in which we fund our our fund our
schools in New Hampshire hopefully that
we can sort of use this as the
springboard to maybe look at that and
and why that is and and follow up some
of the work of the commission and and
hopefully make some changes to the
funding system in New Hampshire so so we
can alleviate or lessen um you know
discrimination based on based on on on
property wealth and property taxes so uh
with that um we're opposed to House Bill
uh 4 uh 455 and I'm happy to take any
questions thank you very much Barett are
there any questions for the school board
Association I don't see any hands up
thank you very much thank you kindly
sir okay next we have Scott Maran uh he
is a me member of the public and uh he
I'm sorry he's an elected official
representing himself and um he opposes
the bill go ahead please Mr Mary and
welcome to education
thank thank you um can you hear me now
sorry about that um just that was funny
I just got kicked off when you moved me
over so um I I don't have much more to
uh say beyond what uh Barrett Christina
just said I'm a member of the Ry School
Board I've been on the Ry school board
for eight years and Ry we're in a pretty
privileged position uh we have uh
property tax revenue and which to draw
doesn't mean that we uh we're not always
watching the bottom line but this notion
of of having kids uh basically just
choose any school they could go it's not
going to solve the property tax or the
uh ZIP code discrimination which I agree
with uh representative cordelli if
that's a problem that we're trying to
address there are structural ways to
address that certainly our housing
policies would be the first things and
and opening up
various towns to different kinds of
affordable housing would be one of the
ways to do that but to think that people
are going to be driving their kids you
know 20 30 50 miles is that's really
setting up a different kind of privilege
because not everybody has a chance to do
that it's going to wreck havocs with
local schools um so again all these
bills that we've been talking about the
past few weeks all seem designed to
avoid dealing with the real problem and
the real problem are the structural
inequities built into our system of
funding uh education here in New
Hampshire I work across the country in
education and I'm embarrassed to say
that I think New Hampshire has the least
Equitable funding system of any of the
states and my organization Works in over
40 States in any state where I work so
let's deal with the real problem and
stop trying to do these workarounds that
are are going to exacerbate the
inequities and wreck havoc with public
education so I yield the rest of my time
thank you for the work you're
doing thank you very much Miss Maran
you've worked with us before we
appreciate all your work in the past and
I still work with the state so I'm
speaking as a rise School Board member
not as a trative thank you are there any
questions for the
presenter not seeing thank you very much
thank you oh wait a minute hold on was
there a question
Mr Woodcock did you have your hand up no
okay no thank you very much thank
you okay uh we had Jane berson bolo from
the New Hampshire Association of special
education Administration scheduled to
speak and I'm just questioning Jane yeah
I'm
here okay I only see a first name there
so want to make
sure
welcome thank thank you so much and I
won't take much of your time I did
submit my written testimony and much of
it has already been touched upon I'm
here representing the special ed
administrators Association and we are in
opposition of the bill in my testimony I
outlined um lots of questions that we uh
are bringing forward some have already
been uh brought to your attention um we
categorized our questions into three
different areas one was just around the
general oversight and responsibility for
special education services um as we
pointed out in our testimony federal and
state law requires school districts to
um have IEP teams that make decisions
around children's uh placements um and
requires districts to place students in
the least restrictive environment
closest to their home this bill um is in
direct conflict with that kind of um
requirement on our school districts the
bill also uh talks about the age ranges
of kids um specifically mentions ages 5
to 20 as all of you know special
education requirements cover ages uh 3
to 21 which again is a is a conflict in
terms of this bill the bill also speaks
to making decisions around students
being placed uh in choice schools that
that has to be done in 10 days it's
virtually impossible in the world of
special education with the timelines and
requirements and meetings that need to
be held um they can't be done legally
within um 10 days you also heard lots of
questions around the expenses related to
special
education and who's going to pay for uh
the special education programming the
related Services the
transportation that is not at all clear
in this bill um the other things that we
mentioned in terms of the criteria and
the denial of school choice we raised
questions it's not clear to us in terms
of students with disabilities and
whether or not they could be denied
school choice because of their placement
you've heard about capacity in the world
of special education there are legal
requirements on the capacity of programs
and the numbers of kids you can put in
so our question is very similar to one
that's already been brought forward if a
classroom a special ed classroom is
almost at capacity and a school choice
student moves in and then you have two
additional students move into their
Hometown are those two students who
moved in not allowed in their own
resident school does the school choice
student get bumped out does the school
district have to the resident District
have to take their resources to expand
their program hire new staff
uh find more space you heard um from car
lad about just the monitoring and
compliance requirements and who's
responsible for all of that to ensure um
that programs are in compliance with all
the requirements and Reporting that's uh
required under um state and federal law
when it comes to special education so
you did receive a full list of all of
our questions um in summary we find that
this bill um has so many flaws and so
many um unanswered questions we would
ask that you uh oppose the bill and
would be happy to take any questions
that you might have on behalf of our
association thank you Jane are there any
questions for the uh School administr
specialist administrators
Association hands up
no don't see any hands Jan thank you
very much thank
you
okay I think that's it
um
speak a total there sorry uh we have 17
opposed I'm sorry 17 support 17 support
479 oppos
479 oos POS one neutral one neutral and
eight testifying and eight
testifying with that we're going to
close this
hearing and we're going to transition
into the next hearing which is HB
282 and I will hand it the G over to
represent Celli as I am the sponsor of
this thank you Mr chairman um I will
open uh the hearing on House Bill 282
relative to a private school that is
approved as a tuition
program and we'll recognize chairman lad
to introduce the Bill thank you very
much representative Cordell for the
record my name is Rick lad I come from
havil New Hampshire and I'm speaking to
HB 282 which deals with the uh tuition
program that we currently have in place
from the state um I'm looking at uh
changing uh basically one word plus a
few others throughout this entire bill I
look first at 1931 col one which is
under School attendance and we currently
have in part D the child is attending a
public or private school located in
another state and or is attending a
nonsectarian private school located in
New Hampshire that is approved as a
school tuition program throughout this
bill not just 1931 but 1933 col or Roman
6 and seven 193 colon 4 liability for
elementary junior high school tuition
198 colum 24 estimates that are relative
to cost 194 colum 27 regarding tuition
all regarding the tuition program
basically the word non secretari and is
being struck out and the word private
school put
in and this uh goes back to uh the issue
of Education choice that we are have
been debating most of today and some on
previous days that and and and
especially going right back to ca cacr 3
from this morning uh where we discussed
why are we discriminating against the
religious school so at in this uh uh
Bill we I have changed the I scratched
nonsectarian and left it that a private
school now secondly I do have an
amendment that was sent out to everybody
I believe
yesterday and one of the the primary
goals of that amendment in Roman
six that would be on this original Bill
starting on line nine and going down
through line 15
that the last portion would have the
sentence the district May either assign
all children to schools that have been
approved as the school of tuition
program and we have that happening in
many school districts in the state this
one southam me has a contract two Antion
contracts with at least four separate
districts in a small k through eight or
allow each child's parent to choose the
school from among those schools or
schools that have been approved as a
School tuition program so if that school
district to the south of me has approved
four contracts with differing school
districts and the contract tuition
rate's not the same for each school
they're negotiating individually with
each School District if a parent says
well school districts one two and three
don't really fit my child but i' like to
have the vot to school district four
that is written into this bill where
that is that can be done in fact that is
being done in some school districts
right now by by putting it into law it's
required that it's got to be considered
and it offers that option to a parent
and that's critical in many of these
smaller towns where the parent best
knows the child and and as familiar
maybe with a school that might be closer
to them or it be a school where a
youngster is uh very interested in art
or theater and there's one school that
might offer a wonderful theater program
or another school might offer a
different program that's what we're
doing with this Contracting right now
throughout this state and parents are
enjoying it and 70% of our parents when
they're they're ped enjoy the option of
having this choice and this opportunity
to tuition their students to a school
and and where they don't have those
grades in the Resident District so I I I
see this as a step forward um I believe
it's the right thing to do it offers us
uh a better degree of school options
that might be affordable or from a
school district perspective often times
and sometimes the tuition rate to some
of these small private schools is less
than it is to the larger school
district and so in the top line of line
three of this it says the child is
attending a public or private school
there's no se some nonsectarian school
on that line says private
school and I believe strong that that
should be the case throughout our
legislation thank you very much and I I
guess I'm done my testimony and welcome
any questions thank you Mr chairman um
any questions from the
committee actually oh I see
representative's
hand I can't put my hand on an amendment
to this bill Rick did did did it come I
checked under your email and I checked
under your wife's email say didn't come
I I would concur on that I don't see it
either nor do
I represent blad I think I have it on
file if you'd like me to send it out to
the
committee surprises me because when I
talked with Mary Ellen
yesterday she said she was GNA send it
out to the house committee also this
committee um and it should should have
been sent
chairman lad do you have the amendment
number yeah I'll introduce that when
okay comme fact written over top so I
can't
mik do you want me to read it for
everybody well it's not necessary to do
it now would do that in executive
session okay thank
you so I apologize to anybody that
doesn't have that amendment I was led to
believe that that would be in your hands
uh we had copy on the table here as Jen
mentioned and U it was supposed to also
been sent electronically to everybody on
the
committee are there
uh other questions possibly uh represent
Tanner yes uh thank you for taking my
question um I'm just
wondering uh if if um you know we had
the the um Constitutional Amendment this
morning
talking about the Blain
amendment I guess can you hear me okay
yes um and also um you know article six
uh that says that no person shall ever
be compelled to pay towards the support
of the schools of any sect or
denomination that wouldn't it be more
prudent to wait until we see how uh the
Constitutional Amendment plays out
before we uh jump into this because
won't this provoke just uh
lawsuits well this this at presently
this particular area of Statute that
we're looking at the 193 198 194 areas
um address not the state making this
decision this is a local school board
decision they're the ones that
approve uh not the state so um it's
still uh it it say within legislation
the the school district made so this is
an option available it's not saying you
shall ass say you may so uh I would
assume then that if it's a decision that
the local school district makes and
wants to go forward with and contrary to
what they have in Massachusetts this is
a local control
state may I have a followup on that yes
you may um doesn't that put the local
school board at risk of a lawsuit then
if uh again we're we're talking about
the New Hampshire constitution in two
separate places and and possible
lawsuits and to the fact that we need a
constitutional amendment
resolution well represent this is a
lawyers world and I guess anything we do
is up for up for grab so uh in today's
society we're kind of a su happy Society
um I would hope that anybody that looks
at this would first look at what is the
best uh education environment available
for this child and I know where I am
right now we don't have choice at all we
don't have a charter school uh we have
uh basically no private schools near us
St Jay Academy is the only one but
that's like 35 40 miles up the road and
a tuition is you know
expensive and transportation's difficult
uh so it's not really an option we have
one private school down in Li New
Hampshire but it's full we have several
Church schools around that are starting
to open up their doors given the the
situation we're encountering now with
the pandemic um and but the way it's
written right now that's not a viable
option may I have it one more
question
she uh thank you um so you know um I
guess the the issue is that maybe uh
what we need to do is put Charter
Schools a charter school uh in each
County or each region so that we have
options that way uh because the
Constitution protects the taxpayer
protects the person who is paying for
the the sectarian school to um promote
their religion uh and I think um that
that uh that's that's the case don't
don't you think that it it this
particular uh Constitutional Amendment
um and or constitutional article
protects the taxpayer I think that what
I prefer look at is that our statutes uh
say that we should provide the
opportunity for all children to receive
an adequate
education and in in some places in our
state here that can't be provided given
a whole host of reasons number one uh
the economics of the environment and the
availability of options uh and there's
absolutely no competition so I would
always take and put the child first and
say what's the best option for the child
I can't imagine anybody wanting to deny
a child and education I for example when
I moved up from Kentucky to Rhode Island
I was a full year behind uh where the
public schools in Rhode Island were my
parents decided me send me to St Dunston
School St dunon is located in Province
rhod and it's an Episcopalian run school
well you know everybody knows that I you
know I'm one of those persons that yes I
believe in religion but I'm very rarely
in church um uh my my mother was a
deaconness in the Presbyterian church
and congregational churches my
grandfather the same yet um when we went
to St Dunston's there was no no religion
taught to me at all it was basically
really I yes I had Latin uh and I was
able to catch up but that provided me an
environment to meet my speeds right if I
gone off to the Middle School in war
Rhode Island I would have never CAU up
uh it was just overwhelming I'd never
seen anything so large in my life it's a
factory and I you know so I think
there's times when we need to have this
available and I leave it to our local
school boards to make the decision
that's proper and right working with the
parent thank
you thank you um any further questions
from the committee representative Mullen
thank you Mr uh thank you representative
cordelli and thank you representative
Vlad for taking another question um so I
I I I have to admit I I'm a little
thrown by not having the amendment in
front of me because my questions are
based on what I think I know not
necessarily what I do know um but let me
just clarify something so you are
according to this bill are proposing
that a school board would be able to
authorize a child or make a
determination that a child's educational
needs are better served at a local
religious school I I'm saying that a
school board that doesn't have for
example grade S8 on up to 12 in their
school district that's going to have to
the kids out somewhere would have this
as one of the options to contract with
and then the the that those choices you
may have four or five different
districts available to parents as we do
in the state right now for a number of
small districts that would be an option
available for the parents to work with
that school district and say I think
Susan really would do best in in this
particular
School are a followup question represent
of cordelli thank you um are you at all
worried about personal bias in the
decision
making personal bias upon who
represen uh personal bias in local
school board
members not feeling that they want to
send local students to uh the Episcopal
School the Jewish Community Center
Saints somewhere um are you what's the
what's the plan
for making sure that people are in
fact not personally biased when they're
making these decisions well first of all
the the local school boards the ones
going to have to set these contracts up
they're going to contract with the
sending
districts uh and then when they have
that list of districts we're just I'm
just throwing in in this Bild the option
where they can contract with a private
uh religious school if they have to or a
private uh you know school like
pness or or some other school that's in
our state that's a small private school
or Monas school as they've done down in
Cy um then it's up to the parent to work
with the school but this the way the
legislation says in the amendment I'm
sorry you don't have it in front of you
it would say or allow each child's
parent to choose a school from among
schools that have been approved as
School tuition program so then the
choice would be handed to the parent and
here's five schools who contracted wood
and here's the strengths and weaknesses
what all these schools and the programs
that are offered um parent we'd love to
hear what your thoughts are on that and
and and help us make that choice in fact
the parent should be allowed to make
that choice because the to prob in most
cases the transportation is going to be
on the shoulders of the the
parent and so would the liability of
success or failure also be with the
parent the the liability is in statute
there when you're looking at the
liability District liability for
elementary junior high school tuition
that's that's spelled out in law
already thank
you any further questions of chairman
lad representative
luno thank you very much Mr chair and
thank you very much representative lad
for taking my question um I'm looking on
the um and and I I did see the amendment
arrive um I think um Miss for uh emailed
it around to the to the committee but
referring back to the um to the bill is
introduced on page one lines 29 and 30
where you refer to um contracted um no
be a school approved and contracted by a
local public school board to provide
students with the opportunity for an
adequate education does that opportunity
for an adequate education basically um
is that shorthand for including all
obligations and requirements and due
process um provisions and everything
that a um that a public school would
otherwise have um be obligated to um to
provide um uh students that it
serves I would reference back to when
we're talking about the opportunity for
an adequate education we you know we'
looked at often up there underneath the
definition of what an adequate education
is and sub
193e me in
193e yeah yeah yeah yeah and and um I'm
I'm not trying to scoot around a quality
education or scoot around standards I'm
just trying to provide that option where
we need some options and places in the
state where um either space is available
in some of them and there might be space
available in another or there's a a
school there available and that's the
only other option available other than
homeschooling and I've been through
homeschooling for the last two months
here or three months and let me tell you
I don't want to do it again um I you
know it's it's probably why I Stumble
here sometimes I'm
tired and so and being a teacher is not
an easy task and you know I was one I
was younger then and it was fun but now
it's fun but it's also exhausting
running around trying to KCK up with
somebody's Middle School Age
kid so I I'm looking for all these
available options and I think that uh
I've seen religious schools that are not
advocating religion in the classroom my
Lord we we made bird houses and
everything else in that Episcopalian
school um they weren't only for
religious Birds they were for everybody
and and so right but but
Rick the the the questions the
question's going to not not whether or
not you choose to attend a religious
school but in the case where a public
school um that doesn't have a school
that serves certain grades contracts
with a private school to fulfill its
Public School obligations and I just was
the the question goes to do all those
Public School obligations travel under
contract to to this contracted private
school or is it just some of the public
schools I think that you're getting the
things for example like we talked about
over in go where they have contracts
with maybe four or five different
schools some schools can
offer programs that other schools cannot
and we have that happening in other
school districts as well and so the and
we've gone down this road with special
education services we know that there's
some situations where special education
may not be done the same way you may see
it done in the public school with the
with the the IEP process and all the
rules and regulations others many
private schools uh choose to direct uh
Supportive Services in a different
manner uh than they do and I don't me to
go through that now I think you're aware
of that um and how that occurs um and
it's effective for some kids I'm not
saying it's effective for all kids and
that's where the parent be allowed to
make this choice and you're going to
make this Choice based upon the
resources and the program Mak going be
provided in that individual
situation yeah and a followup and I
promise this is my last
one um so representative lad um um the
the the line that I was referring to is
in Roman 7 which is uh an approved
School tuition
program um so it's a program that's
been approved by the local school board
as you've as you've pointed out um
to provide um you know to to to provide
um students for the opportunity for that
for for the students that that it serves
I'm not saying it has to be the same as
as another program and I I certainly
understand different schools do
different things not everybody has
football programs not everybody has
robotics teams um and not everybody not
every school district provides the same
the exact same um special education
services but but with the
responsibilities that the public school
I mean with the with the with the with
the school that that is contracted by
the public school have the same
responsibilities they have the
responsibilities as required by that
school board that's approving them and
if you look back at the original
tryonville and that language which we
had it specifies how that is to be done
okay okay thank you very much um I don't
see any further questions from the
committee uh so thank you very much uh
chairman
lad next we have Derek Tremblay um he is
a member of the public and he supports
the bill welcome to education Mr
trumbl
thank you Vice chair cordelli as well as
chairman lad thank you members of the
House Representative U House Education
committee I'm sure you all remember me
from hb20 that was an interesting
session um yes I am here to express my
support for this bill I was not able to
be present this morning um when you were
discussing the repeal of the Blain
Amendment so some of what I'm going to
say now which is in addition to my
written testimony you likely already
heard I would just encourage you all to
make sure you visit
um there are three cases at the federal
level which establish um the
constitutionality of sending students to
what we're calling sectarian or I would
call a religious school that's zelman
versus Simmons Harris that's the voucher
program over in the state of Ohio that's
Trin Lutheran versus comr and then the
more recent Espinosa versus
Montana I think in esposa versus Montana
we found that there are two sides of
that first um First Amendment there's
the free exercise and then the
non-establishment clause and I think
we're kind of living in times right now
where we put that divisive line between
the two and we can't see the Nuance that
you can do both at the same time which
uh at least here in chairman lad I think
this is trying to accomplish that by
giving parents the choice uh for the
education of their children and then the
only other point that I would make
without taking up too much of your time
is I I just want to make this argument
as the leader of a religious school um
after hearing especially representative
Tanner saying that religious schools
just want to propagate the faith I would
argue that religious schools just like
public schools have the good of the
child as their sole objective and
nothing else and I thank you for your
time uh thank you very much Mr chle um
any questions take questions y y
questions from the
committee representative uh
lunar thank you very much Mr chairman
and thank you very much um Mr tremble um
do does the the school that you head up
um currently take um special education
students uh yes sir and and a followup
on that yes sir do do parents have a um
a due process right uh to um to
challenge I mean a due process right to
to contest um the
IEP yes sir yeah as far as I know even
though they parentally placed I think
you've probably heard this before they
still are under you know Ida entitled to
all those
rights um I I think we could get some
clarification on that I don't and I
maybe I can understand your question
better what do you mean by protest
representatively I didn't say protest I
said due process due process and and
it's a it it's actually a right for for
due process that um it's it's not it's
not just whether or not the school wants
to allow the parents to meet with the
board or something like that to to
discuss um their their child but it's
actually a right toh to do that and I
think my understanding from from prior
testimony not on this bill but on
another bill is that when a when a when
a a when a student exits their Public
School District they they also leave
their IDE rights
um I I think that I think they forfeit
their their idea rights would you mind
if I just speak to my experience and
that could be helpful here given maybe
we're both a little unsure but I can
just tell you I've
sat I've sat in those meetings um where
the due process is taking place and it's
always read to the parent that they do
have due process um and then we all kind
of sign consent agreements so if that's
what we're referring to that's my
knowledge of due
process thank you very much um I see
noan oh repres
Tanner I please go ahead thank you um i'
just like to to mention that I I really
didn't uh imp mean to imply that the
only thing that religious schools teach
are religion um I grew up in
Pennsylvania where Quaker schools were
very prominent down around the
Philadelphia area and they had a very
high rating for academic standards um
and uh you know I think that that uh non
sectarian schools uh and sectarian
schools um probably are you know they're
they're fine um products of people from
both um I have no problem with that um
and I just want to make that clear I
also uh wanted to just say that uh you
know I think that uh they offer a good
education for those families that wish
to bring their child up in that uh that
religion and that academic uh atmosphere
so um I wanted to make my position clear
thank you thank you uh if there are no
further questions for Mr Chay I thank
you very
much okay uh next we have Barrett
Christina hello again from the New
Hampshire School Board Association good
afternoon thank you representative
Hobson uh thank you representative
cordelli for recognizing me Barett
Christina um executive director New
Hampshire school boards Association um
one quick um ask of the committee um
when I did sign up to register I did
sign up an opposition to the bill um
I've had a chance to reread it and
contemplate a little bit about it if if
nhba could testimony could just be
identified as neutral or not taken a
specific position we'd certainly
appreciate that um I I will agree that I
think the espo a decision um does um uh
make for the necessity to remove the the
non- sectarian um language that's
currently in the law um so in consistent
with that with that Supreme Court
opinion um nhba still does have concerns
over um the general policy aspects of
the cin bill which was Senate Bill 8
back in I believe 2017 if that was um
and the only other concern that nhba has
and it's not so much the sectarian
aspect or non sectarian aspect with
respect to the bill but rather sort of
the broader policy aspects of um of of
of the of of the cyen Bill of Senate
Bill 8 um if a school board that if a
school district that does not have
schools um doesn't operate any schools
chooses to send its children to a a
religious school under that the cyen
bill program I have concerns that and
and that
children may be forced for lack of a
better phrase to attend a religious
school that may be contrary to their
religious beliefs um so for example my
understanding is that Goan New Hampshire
does not operate any schools I think
they have 60 kids maybe 80 kids I forget
exactly how many um and for a number of
years they sent their kids to um uh to
Newport um and I now I think they have
some sort of public school choice
program um within within go
and also my understanding that um the
individual from out Royal Academy has
approached the Goan school board and
asked about um uh having the the Goan
School Board um send some of the
children to uh to Mount Royal Academy
excuse me if that were to say an
exclusive contract um under the the
school board approval program um where
all students had to attend Mount Royal
Academy and I'm assuming it's a k
through2 school I don't know anything
about the school um I think that would
would be problematic um you know
certainly the school board has a right
to do that under this bill and removing
the nonsectarian language they would
have the right to do that but I'm
worried about the impact on the kids who
may not um share sort of the doctrinal
beliefs that the religious school um
might have um or might require so I I
think that could be a matter of contract
obviously to some degree between the
public school and the and the private
school but I'm just thinking of a
situation where a district that does not
operate any schools if they were to
engage in a a contract K through 12 um
and it was a singular contract an
exclusive contract between the religious
school and the and the public school and
the the the school board to send their
kids there I'd be worried about the kids
who may not share that particular Faith
or that particular religion so those are
my only comments about that um again if
if nhba testimony could be identified as
being neutral on this bill we'd
appreciate that change um but with that
um I'm happy to answer any questions of
the committee has thank you we uh we did
note that change any questions from the
committee around I do not see any so
thank you very much thank you very much
representative
cordelli okay next we have Jody
Underwood she is an elected official
testifying on behalf of herself she
supports the
bill welcome to education
again sorry was that for me yes that's
for you okay again get thrown out of
Zoom when you start announcing it's very
strange Sor it's okay um good afternoon
everybody my name for the record is Jody
Underwood I am still the vice chair of
the cyen school
board cin will be directly affected by
this bill should it become lack so the
addition of the term non sectarian was
made as a compromise during the passage
of the cin Bill to avoid Court
challenges over whether towns could
tuition students to religious private
schools now it needs to be changed to
avoid Court challenges again maybe
you're aware that there's already a
court case pending um and that's because
it's in support of the federal decision
that said it would be discrimination to
exclude religious schools when other
private schools are offered in a school
choice
program as for I was curious about this
it rep representative Mullen asked about
local bias um districts aren't actually
placing students in religious schools
parents for from for Town tuition this
is how tuition works at least in a place
like cin parents will choose the school
according to their preferences so I'm
not sure what you meant where the bias
would would come in um although I do um
recognize um baric Christina's comment
um as being valid that if we only had a
religious school then it would be uh
essentially a placement and that is
where um where it differs I I think that
that probably should be stated more
clearly that it shouldn't be allowed to
be the only choice
um so to continue um if cacr 3 is
successful in removing the Blain
Amendment from the state constitution
then that will um close the challenge
for the a constitutional challenge right
that will make that disappear however as
long as sectarian schools are excluded
by Statute an opening will remain to
challenge any school district that tries
to save its taxpayers money to provide
some of its students with better
education according to their parents'
choice and also respect the experience
and expertise of parents regarding their
own
children of course having said all that
the bill would be improved and we can
argue about this if instead of removing
nonsectarian to change it to sectarian
or non- sectarian which would make the
intent of the bill clear enough to be
understood by anybody um including um to
be a little um including um judges in
the courts who as I've said twice today
already seem to take words out to to
lead to their own um how they want the
outcome to to be and that ends my
testimony very much any questions for
Miss Underwood represent
Mullen not a question just a point of
clarification to uh Miss Underwood that
representative lad's Amendment uh
indicates that the school district will
assign or the parent will choose I was
looking for Clarity on the difference in
the
processes thank you uh seeing nothing
further um I thank you very much for
your testimony this afternoon thank you
thank you next we have Kirby
West out of the institute for justice
and uh Kirby supports the bill go ahead
please hi uh thank you for the
opportunity to speak I'm Kirby West I'm
an attorney with the institute for
justice I'm also the attorney that's
representing Dennis and Katherine
Griffin in their current lawsuit against
the New Hampshire Department of
Education about the town tuition program
and so to representative um Tanner's
concern about future litigation this
program is already the subject of
litigation um and that litigation would
actually be resolved by this um House
Bill 282 which this this bill would
solve the problems that we rais in our
lawsuit um as a quick background our
lawsuit is challenging the exclusion of
religious schools from the town tuition
program um our clients the Griffins live
in Cen New Hampshire which you just
heard from Miss Underwood is a two iing
town they send their grandson Clayton to
Mount Royal Academy and the Cen School
District would like to pay for his
tuition at Mount Royal Academy but can't
under the current statute and House Bill
282 would eliminate the exclusion that
restricts cin in this way resolving the
problems we rais in our lawsuit and AC
accomplishing two important purposes um
first as I believe you all heard this
morning with regard to the blank
Amendment a recent ruling by the United
States Supreme Court held that the
exclusion of religious schools from
Choice program solely because they are
religious violates the First Amendment
so the current exclusion violates this
constitutional protection and I believe
if this if this um House Bill 282 does
not pass will ultimately be struck down
by the court anyway just at greater
expense second house bill 282 removes
some of the ambiguity from the statute
and makes clear to school districts what
their options are under the law if they
are a tuition in
town although the school districts who
lack a a school for certain grade levels
May already choose to allow parents to
select the school that their child
attends as cin does um this
clarification in the language makes that
option more clear and ensures that all
tuition and towns know that they can
offer this choice to
families um for these reasons we would
support the passage of House Bill 282
and I'd be happy to take any
questions
are there any questions for attorney
West I'm not seeing see none thank you
very much for your time today thank you
very much thank
you uh we did have car Carl lad
scheduled to speak but I believe he has
dropped he dropped
off so that's all I have I think that's
uh all the people who want to testify uh
on House Bill 282 so I will uh close the
hearing
and want me to read do you have the I
have the totals yes uh we have 12 signed
in in
support 162 oppose one neutral that's
the School Board Association change and
um a total of six
testified well one one didn't yeah one
was
actually five four
actually thank you very much thank you
turn the Reigns back over to Chairman
lead thank you very much uh so with that
we this hearing is closed and uh we've
gone through our the hearings support
today and uh at this point in time it's
going on quarter three I don't think I'm
going to go on and do any excting this
afternoon um I will move into that and
start working on those bills uh next
week uh we have the uh six bills I
believe or so to deal with in hearing
still and then um then we're getting
into the ex we have at least 30 of those
bills that's an approximation so we have
a work out of course um but I think that
we're going to be able to get done uh we
have one two three four five six seven
Bill scheduled for the hearings on uh
the 9th so that's on Election Day uh and
then uh the following day on that
Thursday we certainly will be exacting
bills um so with that uh we're gonna
wrap it up today I know there are some
folks that places to go and things to do
so are there any questions or comments
from committee members as to this
point not seeing any thank you very much
and we're Jour have a good weekend
good
luck okay we got turn off
that
I